foreign
all right good morning welcome to a
meeting of the special committee on
housing uh we're gonna get started
shortly I just want to start with a few
quick announcements I want to call on uh
representative Damon who can who wants
to make an announcement
thank you very much
um I just want to make sure people are
aware of the annual meeting of New
Hampshire
oh dear me brain cramp hold on
historical preservation commission is
this Friday it's an all-day Workshop
meeting in Claremont they're awarding
chinberg for restoring one of the old
mills there into 83
apartment rentals that were rented
before it was built and various other
workshops uh offering information on
Housing and Development so I just want
to make sure people were aware that
that's happening thank you
thank you representative
um so representative Wallace can you
give us a little bit of detail on the
amendment that you were circling around
in Municipal and County and uh give it
as an update sure as uh as we've
discussed
um the committee has identified a couple
of areas that we can take some what we
thought could be some pretty immediate
action uh specifically with reference to
requiring only
zoning ordinances uh building codes fire
codes plumbing codes and uh things of
that nature that are in effect at the
time of issuance of the building permit
much like we're constrained to not make
any retrospective law that particular
amendment to SB 78 was was ruled
not germane enough so we won't be able
to move on that at this point in time so
we're going to put a Billet in the fall
uh chair and vice chair of Municipal
County government saw fit uh with this
particular idea that they feel strong
enough to get on board as sponsors as
well so uh I'll submit that this fall
with my fellow members of the committee
as co-sponsors
and hopefully things will move forward
without hedge my hope is that we can get
everybody on this committee on board
but that we'll we'll look at the
language in the fall but thank you Scott
that's at least one thing coming out of
this committee is something we've seen
is a something easy that we can get done
and so hopefully there's more things
that we can move forward on so at this
point I want to call on dick anagnos
from anagnos Realty development good
morning
and if you could dick just turn your mic
on for us
thank you
oh I didn't even I'm sorry I didn't even
do the pledge do you mind
and to the Republic for which it stands
one nation under God indivisible with
liberty justice for all
there we go yes thank you
thank you Ben that's right
um just press the button now there is it
on now perfect thank you
uh first
thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to appear before you today
um this is a very serious issue in our
state and it's an issue I've been
dealing with for close to 40 years
um
I know that the committee is doing great
work in in trying to make inroads into
um the issue of Housing and within the
state of New Hampshire and it's not just
Workforce and affordable housing that we
need we need all types of housing which
New Hampshire housing is here and
they'll elaborate a lot more than that
then I will be able to however the way I
got into building Workforce and
affordable housing is because my
employees couldn't find a place to live
and this is back in the 1980s so this is
a deal uh situation that we've been
dealing with for a very long time
in my opinion though this is a solvable
issue
the problem is there's been no
Constitution or or
effort put forth to solve it as a result
of our
own inability to get out of our own way
sometimes
so the major issue that that
you people are attempting to solve is a
lack of housing the reason that there's
a lack of housing is because there is
impediments to building housing at a
lower cost
those impediments come as a result of
home rule which I am fully in favor of
however
um
Saint anselms College recently did some
good work on the atlas which you guys
are aware of that put out before us a
glaring picture of how bad off we really
are that there's no continuity of
Regulation
that everybody's interpretation of the
ordinances and the regulations that
they've created is different
there's even from my experience the
interpretation of regulations from
sector within the same government from
the building department to the playing
Department that are different from one
another all of those things create
uncertainty in when you have uncertainty
it costs money
the
government cannot solve this alone the
private sector can solve the housing
issue and it can solve it without the
resources that you guys have been
putting forth because you'll never put
enough resources forth to be able to pay
enough money you'll never be able to
develop enough resources to pay enough
money to solve the problem
the way we're doing it now
I was the first developer in the state
who used low-income housing tax credit
program in 87 which it was initiated in
86. I am the largest private developer
of Workforce housing in the state having
developed over 2 000 units of it either
in partnership with New Hampshire
Housing partnership with the Manchester
Housing and Redevelopment partnership
with National Housing Redevelopment
partnership with HUD directly so I have
a lot of experience developing these
kinds of
programs are utilizing the programs and
the programs themselves will not solve
the problem what will solve the problem
is
two things one of them it's called
planning which is something we don't do
very much of in New Hampshire what we do
is we have knee-jeric reactions
okay so if there's a blip where the
schools are overcrowded there's no more
housing that's allowed in one way or
another it's defeated
either through directly saying we don't
want your project or through providing
obstacles that we can't overcome in
order to develop the project cost
effectively
there's a which New Hampshire is known
for that's why we're the first in the
nation primary there's a significant
amount of nimbyism which you guys are
aware of
um
in a recent project I had my Butters
were in favor of the project but other
townspeople were not in the latest over
two years
through different ways of
um
of bringing forth
unfounded
um
concerns that just continued to cost us
more money to to prove that they were
unfounded concerns in the end they were
all unfounded concerns and one of the
funniest results is the project is now
open and operating and the people that
were against I think it's absolutely
beautiful
but moving on from there there were two
major issues that I'd like to address
one of them is planning
our local municipalities received their
right to Zone and create regulations
from our legislature okay zoning all
stems The Authority all stems from the
legislature the only way that we're
going to solve this is the legislature
needs to put together a cohesive program
with either a stick in a carrot that
allows or that essentially demands that
local municipalities adhere to
um the need to address these housing
situations and I could sit here and tell
you horror shows that I've been through
I won't waste your time with all of that
um things that have been done to
obstruct And Delay
outright picketing
um literally threats at some points in
time I mean it goes on and on but
realistically we're looking for a
solution we're not looking to go back in
history and correct what's been done so
the solution is the first part of the
solution in my opinion is something
needs to be done at the state level it
brings all the municipalities in line
and agree that if you do this then you
get this if you don't do that then you
don't get this either that or I know
that the gov owner is recently working
on an incentive program but what I've
run into in the local municipalities is
okay they give us an incentive we don't
want it okay we'd rather keep our town
exactly the way it is we don't want the
character change and no matter what you
bring in the character is going to
change
so the carrot really hasn't worked well
over the years the stick is going to
have to be utilized at some point
going along with that the key to
developing housing is density
that's a four-letter word by any
proficient speller in the development
business okay because density is what
everybody does not want
when you hear the word density they
think of projects when you hear the word
density they think of overcrowding when
you hear the word density they think of
tons of school children when you hear
the word density they say our traffic
impacts are going to be
irrehensible or our inability to deal
with them none of that is factual those
are the arguments we've been overcoming
for years to get what limited housing
we've been able to do now
but think about this for a second if you
there was a little bit of planning
meaning
somebody looked at their town map and
said we have water and sewer here we
have good access to roads here we have
adjacency to Services here and said
we're going to make this zone for
multi-family for condos for high low or
smaller lot sizes okay and we take a
step back and we go to our forefathers
and we look at how Manchester I'll use
as an example was developed
the mill him Escape Mills came in they
built the Mills and the first ring
around the Mills what did they put high
density housing multi-family and the
next ring around the multi-family what
did they put
small lot single family housing and the
next ring around now what happened Elm
Street was developed and that's where
they put Commercial Services
so therefore I'm not
advocating for some new Village type
um development here I'm advocating to go
back to what we knew worked okay
um producing a brand new project right
now
it consists of 280 000 square feet of
Industrial Development which is going to
produce 1200 jobs and we already have
the business that's going to move into
it
we have no place to put those workers so
on the same site we're proposing 304
Apartments we're proposing twenty
thousand square feet of small retail so
that they can go to the store and get
something so that they can go to their
gyms so that they can go to get their
hair done or whatever the case may be
and we're proposing a ten thousand
square foot daycare because what's our
next number one problem after housing is
what do we do with our children
we're going to be a self-contained unit
in the 90s I dealt with an international
corporation in Ohio and we came in and
planned the exact same thing they put
their big automobile manufacturing plant
in the middle
right around it they put the support
businesses that were going to be
necessary around that they put high
density housing for their workers around
that they put single-family
housing for their workers around that
they put executive housing for their
Executives and then around that we
placed all of the retail and services to
support the overall development you know
Ohio is accepted immediately in New
Hampshire I've run into well this
doesn't meet this regulation this
doesn't meet that regulation you're
going to have to get over this hurdle
you need a variance you need a variance
for your retail you need a variance for
your residential you need
um you need to go get a special waiver
in order to have daycare there
so the impediments that have been
created we've created ourselves okay now
we need a way to remove those
impediments
I want to go back to density for a
second we talked about a little bit of
planning so if that planning was to say
that 5 000 foot Lots were relative you
could put a significant number of homes
single-family homes and a very small
piece of land Manchester did it
at one point Manchester when Amelia was
originally created the size of the Lots
was 2500 square feet if it had water in
sewer then they went to five thousand
then they started with r1a and r1b and
they went from 5000 in this Zone to 7
500 to 12 500
um so even there where they have a very
Progressive zoning it's still a
situation where if it was all right for
my family to live
50 years ago in a 5 000 square foot lot
why is it not all right today and that
was considered entry level housing those
homes were sold at a reasonable amount
and you could build them at a reasonable
amount because you weren't paying for X
number of miles of your own
in another municipality in the one I
live in I had 300 acres of land
300 acres of land got me 96 homes
because I have a two acre minimum a 200
foot Frontage I have to have buried
underground utilities I have to have a
drainage system even though I don't have
enclosed drainage I have enclosed
drainage in my project that leads the
open Swale drainage
all of that incurred cost as cost is
increased that the developer the cost of
the land goes up as the cost of the Lots
go up the cost of the housing also has
to go up
when you're looking at conservation
which we are
very much in favor of in the state of
New Hampshire
what did I conserve by building almost
five miles of roadway what did I
conserve by putting in five miles of
drainage what that I can serve by by
digging up and putting five miles of
underground utilities of that 300 acres
I'm impacting a hundred I donated 200 to
be into conservation I could have put
that 96 homes on 30 Acres
okay it would have been more cost
effective for me I'd have clustered them
together I'd have concentrated the
utilities I'd have concentrated the
drainage and I'd have preserved another
70 Acres on top of it and over and above
that I'd have been able to increase the
density almost double
the situation is such where density
should be driven by land loading you
have Wetlands you have slopes when known
as the granite state there's ledge
everywhere
but if you have a piece of land and I'm
going to describe to a real life
circumstance where I add 10 acres of
land
and the 10 acres of land was perfect
it had water and sewer it had gas it was
flat it had no Wetlands it had five
small little pockets where a farmer had
um
dug up a rot and it turned into a Vernal
pool the total impact on 10 acres of the
Wetland was about 2 500 square feet
really minimal
I was adjacent to Services
it had everything going for it that you
would want in a multi-family housing
project
when I first started developing in this
town in late 1970s the eunuch density
was 24 units per acre
it's currently nine
the land loading we did an experiment we
brought in the engineers and we said
how many units could we put on this site
that we could load on the land with the
services we have
they came back with about 300 we got 90.
Okay so
if I had put 300 number one the land
costs would have been a lot less number
two the land would have supported it
number three I could have rented those
units at significantly less money
because now I've spread my costs over
300 units instead of over 90.
so the whole concept of solving the
issue is going to come down to we need
to rewrite our regulations to some
planning and create density and
everybody says okay density is
multi-family density is not just
multi-family density is townhouses
density is small single family lots in
the south side of Manchester if you
drive there I defy you to find many lots
that are over five or seven thousand
square feet okay it has worked in the
past and it will work going forward and
it's because we got away from our Basics
because we were knee-jerk reacting to
whatever impediment was before us at
that time whether it had been in the 80s
explosive growth whether had been
converting everybody to 55 and older if
you were going to get an approval in any
reasonable period of time
I mean where the I think the Second
Great most graying State we created that
problem on our own we allowed the we
didn't allow the local planning boards
allowed expedited approvals if you were
55 and older and you weren't bringing
any children
whereas my projects were taking two and
three years because I was looking for
multi-family that included children
I was looking for Workforce housing I've
had more objections to Workforce housing
than any of my projects each time I
bring forth Workforce housing
as a result of the fact that everybody
conjures up a project and I've literally
had people tell me that as soon as I
um mentioned the project that I was
having every drug dealer and Drug user
coming there and these are the
perceptions that we need to get over
because that's not the truth by any
stretch of the imagination
but we Face these impediments because
we're labeled
when we say Workforce when we say
affordable we're labeled with a negative
connotation and the only people that
come out in a planning board meeting are
the minority that are against it okay
the majority never comes out the
majority never supports
had the majority been there and your
elected officials
um I thank you for your service because
it's not easy you have constituents
constituents that don't like your point
of view or don't like what you're
advocating on their behalf so rocks and
stones at you so imagine a poor planning
board member sitting up there who's got
his next door neighbor is pointing at
him and saying you're ruining our
neighborhood because you're going to
allow affordable housing into it they're
under a significant amount of pressure
if the majority of the neighborhood was
there saying we support you it would be
a heck of a lot easier for them to make
the right decision
the
next and final point that we'll take to
solve this one is planning the other one
is density and the other one
representative Scott was just mentioning
and that is
um housing codes
okay so housing codes continue to get
worse and worse and worse year to year
to year
if in fact the legislature adopts the
proposed 2023
[Music]
um
what is it called
I don't remember exactly what the bill
is but it has to do with installation
and Energy savings and that kind of
stuff
um
it will add around 12 to 15
000 per multi-family unit
because we'll have to use all mechanical
um
ventilation within the units because
they'll be building the building so
tight that the buildings don't breathe
any longer
energy will be so tight that the
buildings won't breathe any longer and
if you don't have a building that breeze
brings in fresh air you've got to do it
some way so now we're going to be
ducting
um ventilators and fins into every
single unit
rather than how many years did we build
successfully without this regulation so
you know this
movement to
save energy and to conserve energy is
actually working opposing the ability to
produce affordable housing
um
the codes themselves are written for
something that's constructed new
we have a built environment Manchester
Nashua Rochester and conquered okay we
have a built environment
we can renovate schools Office Buildings
buildings that we've successfully
utilized and changed their life by
turning them into housing one of the
largest impediments to rehabbing and
turning something into housing is that
the building was built in the early
1900s and the late 1800s and trying to
adapt those buildings
to current codes as if you were building
a brand new construction is almost
impossible
I started in tried it in Manchester on
the main on Elm Street Elm Street was a
Dragway I opened up the first buildings
brought to First businesses I attempted
to build housing in the upper floors
which is what was there
when the muskeg Mills were operating
there was a first level was always
retail the second and third levels were
typically office space and then above
those were typically housing
a lot of housing units exist there but
they don't meet any code
a number of years back we attempted to
bring before the legislature a
combination of Rhode Island and New
Jersey's codes for the rehab of
buildings
to get a stairwell that is acceptable
today to the fire department into one of
those buildings yeah you're going to
have to demolish most of the building
and be you're going to have to take up a
lot of valuable space
we went through an exercise on one
building in Manchester where we got
flexibility by not tearing out the
stairwells in the walls and that sort of
thing what we did was in one building we
kept the original stairwells in the
front and built a larger stairwell in
the rear and it was acceptable to the
fire department at the time
another thing we did was we had the
original
tin walls and ceilings and stuff that
was very very historic that was in
really good shape they wanted us to
cover it with two two layers of five Ace
fire rated sheetrock
um in order to meet the fire code what
we did there is we came up with an
Innovative way to run two sprinkler
lines down a hallway
and create a quarter of water so what we
did was instead of making the walls the
protected Corridor we created a quarter
within the quarter of a curtain of water
on both sides so that someone could walk
down through that curtain of water to
the exit just a lot of creative things
that we can do in order to meet the
codes however there's a little appetite
to accept those kind of innovative ideas
the appetite typically that we run into
or the attitude that we typically run
into is this is the code that you need
to meet
this is the only way that's acceptable
to meet the code and put two layers of
five Ace fire rated on both sides so you
have a rated hallway and unless you do
that we're not going to give you an
approval
so we need to be more Innovative in our
thinking and adopt Innovative codes
okay and somehow that needs to be
communicated to the towns that they need
to follow these codes
we need to do some planning or Force the
towns to do some planning be proactive
instead of reactive
and place make Provisions for this type
of Housing and when I say this type it's
all types of housing
thirdly density needs to be addressed
and if you can get those three three
things into a developer's hands you're
going to see that as long as he can make
a profit he is going to be able to build
housing that can be
good clean housing that can be
affordable in nature to the people that
are in New Hampshire working for a
living it astounds me when I go before a
planning board and they say the resident
gets up and say we don't want those type
of people in our
um
in our town the interesting part about
it though is in one town I'll give you a
real life example I built a project that
was 25 Workforce housing
and in that 25 Workforce housing I have
seven police officers one firefighter
four teachers all that work within the
confines of that town
when I went to build the sister project
to it again with 25 percent Workforce
housing because their own town ordinance
says that if you're going to build a
multi-family project you have to have 25
percent Workhorse housing
I was met with Pittsburgh quarks and
machetes by most of the Town saying we
don't want those people in our town
even after the school teacher and the
police officer testified on our behalf
that we live here in this town and we
work here in this town and if we didn't
have these housing available to us we
wouldn't be able to do that they still
fought against the project
so there are four things one of them is
planning one of them is zoning density a
third one is codes and then the fourth
one is we need to go through an attitude
change somehow in some way that says
that everybody has the right to live
here and everybody has the right to good
clean housing and everybody has the
right to be able to afford that housing
within the salaries that they're being
paid
short of doing that I wish you a lot of
luck
you have a Herculean job on your hands
we've been trying to do a lot of this
for many many years unsuccessfully
um in by way of example a number of
years back when in soon as first term I
sat on a panel where we came up with the
idea of having
um a board to review
um approvals from towns which you guys
finally got approved and what happened
the following year there was a movement
to repeal of it before it even had a
chance to operate okay so that's the
kind of hurdle that you guys are facing
I'd love to entertain any direct
questions you may have thank you very
much for your presentation it's been
helpful and I feel like it's kind of
dovetailed with a lot of other
presentations I think we we see the
writing on the wall here a lot of a lot
of what you're saying
um does anybody have questions yep
represent broody thank you Mr chairman
dick thank you very much for coming
today
um
I know when I asked you to come we had a
discussion and you said you had a
kind of working on a plan with Governor
Benson and then of course uh he didn't
get reelected and Governor Lynch didn't
like your plan so
um it sounded interesting to me and
maybe it would be uh stir up some
interest here if you want to elaborate
on that a little so Governor Benson
asked me to undertake a study and I wish
I'd still had it but to determine what
the real impediments were and a lot of
those impediments remain today and a lot
of them we've just discussed the
governor has been an idea at the time
was
the state funds municipalities in a lot
of different ways whether it be Highway
funds whether it be rooms and meals tax
or you know there's a whole lot of Aid
that comes from the state that goes to
each municipality Governors Benson ID
Governor Benson's idea at the time was
to tie
all of that state aid that each
municipality gets to their ability to
produce
good clean affordable housing
so I don't know if that's a reasonable
option either but that was being pursued
at the time when the election took place
and Governor Lynch took over Governor
Lynch didn't like the idea of of holding
the town's hostage with state aid in
order to achieve a goal so that was the
idea representative Rudy that Benson had
come up with that if the states could if
the state could bring to the town's
attention the fact that they were
significantly deficient in their ability
to produce housing as a result of their
own codes then the state was going to be
holding whatever monies that they would
be entitled to over their head until
they solved that issue
thank you very much apology so instead
of holding a town hostage under that
same
framework Maybe
give the town an incentive instead of
holding something back give them
something extra if they would do
something like this well I've run into
that and the governor current governor
has attempted to do that with New
Hampshire Housing and it hasn't worked
very successfully because if you already
have what you want
why are you enticed to take something
more than what you want in order to
compromise what you think isn't the
right thing to do
okay so the incentive only works if
there's an appetite to accept the
incentive or if the incentive is large
enough which will never have enough
money to do that the incentive is large
enough in order to motivate them to
change the regulations okay the only
thing that's really going to work in my
opinion is stick and naturally you're
going to have the municipal Association
all over you guys and
um you know there'll be significant
lobbying on behalf of home rule and that
you guys have taken over but one of the
things that is a bad word in
Massachusetts but it works is something
called 40b okay and in 40b in
Massachusetts it's a law under which
if a developer brings in a project into
a municipality
you know I'm going to just give you the
rough interpretation
and he's going to put in housing as long
as he's going to commit to 20 of that
housing being affordable or Workforce
then he can go to the state for his
approvals and completely circumvent
approvals within the town
okay and even though that's a a tool
that's used regularly in Massachusetts
and
and towns can't stand it because
the state has usurped their ability to
hear the project
it definitely gets everybody's attention
when you're walking in and say I am just
going to go 40b the Town becomes a
little more Cooperative with you if they
don't want you to do it and if they're
just going to dig their heels in you
just go to the state and get your
approvals anyway
so I'm not advocating that that's the
best solution for New Hampshire but
that's one solution that appears to work
in Massachusetts does bring on in every
one of those projects 20 of Workforce or
affordable housing as a result of it
the housing Champion
certification that's making its way over
that does some of that carrot stuff but
I think dick is right that there's some
municipalities that it's not enough it's
usually not enough for them to want to
adopt those changes
um representative Gibbs thank you Mr
chairman and um thank you for coming
here today sir uh uh are you familiar
with the U.S Department of Housing and
Urban Development HUD uh requirement
that uh recipients have had assistance
do an analysis of fair housing showing
what impediments they have in in their
municipality uh to fair housing and how
they are going to further fair housing
we use a lot of Hud assistance now I
mean I've developed probably close to 5
000 apart not Apartments housing units
in the state of New Hampshire I've used
every program that's out there I've used
HUD D4 I've used HUD 223 I've used New
Hampshire I have a very long-standing
relationship with New Hampshire Housing
and their light tech program
we've used Bond financing through the
state of New Hampshire in order to get
deals done but to go directly to your
question
um
that assessment currently is done now
annually and it's called a react
inspection HUD
forces it that all of the dollars that
have gone into your project as a result
of them investing in your project they
put you through a react inspection which
makes sure that all of those housing
units meet their appropriate levels of
Code Enforcement so that you have good
clean housing uh this actually goes
beyond
um the react inspection this is a
separate
analysis or assessment that cities and
towns and states that receive HUD
funding are required to do
to show what impediments they have to
fair housing which clearly uh as as
you've explained the desire to exclude
those people
is very common and
um this is something that uh
cities and towns of states that receive
HUD funding are are required to review
and show HUD how they're going to
correct it
um and this obviously is not going to
apply uh to every municipality in New
Hampshire
but a number of them do get HUD funding
directly and
um
uh also
um quite a few uh get HUD funding
um on a year by year basis through the
state so uh do you think that if if we
looked at those assessments
um that we might be able to
um uh
shall we say find some things that that
ought to be corrected again that
attitude of let's not have those people
here
um is obviously part of the problem yes
and to further on something or to
expound upon something I said earlier I
understand your question I I'm sorry I
answered it inappropriately with react
okay so the only two directly entitled
communities I'm aware of of Nashua and
Manchester from HUD and I noted through
the HUD system we do a lot of other
municipalities but the prevalent
attitude that I deal with is okay you
want to give us that funding please keep
the HUD funding and also you keep all of
this housing out of our town
okay that's the prevalent attitude
HUD funding to a municipality if you're
Progressive like Manchester Nashua is an
advantage if you're in some of the other
surrounding towns to Manchester and
Nashua they would rather say thank you
very much for your HUD funding you can
keep the HUD funding and therefore we
don't have to bring any of your
Workforce housing into our municipality
so HUD does a great job of like I said
through the react inspection of making
sure that we have good clean housing but
Hud's ability or the ability to receive
HUD funds to me in my opinion is not a
motivating influence in a town to say if
we don't want Workforce or affordable
housing we don't want that opportunity
in our town please just keep your
funding it'll be an easy way for them to
avoid it
well this afternoon we'll be
uh follow up yes thank you
um uh I'm just uh gonna say you might be
interested to know that this afternoon
we're going to be hearing from the New
Hampshire commission for human rights
which is the state's anti-discrimination
agency and also from the um uh New
Hampshire field office director of Hud
so they'll be able to uh talk more about
that
um there are a couple of other
entitlement communities
um I retired
um seven years ago now so I don't have
it all in my head the way I used to uh I
worked at full disclosure I worked for
HUD for 29 years in the office of fair
housing and equal opportunity
um but
um uh just a suggestion that you might
want to
just keep that in mind when when you're
talking to municipalities I commend your
service with HUD HUD isn't the easiest
organization to be able to work with for
a long period of time but um I have
actually been to Washington I've
testified before Senate subcommittees
and House subcommittees commissioned
with respect to HUD regulation I've been
down to Huda headquarters and testified
there as well as to the impediments to
do this in New Hampshire and
unfortunately my testimony seems to be
the same it's very repetitive without
the private sector we don't solve this
government cannot solve the housing
problem it's impossible anyone that
thinks it can will be paying so many
taxes that we will not be able to afford
government by the time we try to solve
the housing problem it has to be solved
by the private sector what you need to
do to solve the problem bring in the
private sectors give us the tools to do
it okay you created all of the tools
that are in place now and you've they've
been created in such a way where they're
not workable and we're failing miserably
at our ability to achieve okay what you
need to do is throw all those rules Out
start over again and give us the tools
by which to go solve this problem in the
private sector we'll solve it private
sector solves everything as long as a
developer can make a profit
building it two thousand square foot or
1500 square foot first time house okay
and it's a reasonable profit which
developers used to make roughly 20
percent their margins have been squeezed
down to around nine percent now so you
don't see a lot of people building and
doing this because it's almost not worth
doing any longer
but as long as there was a program under
which we could develop and we could make
a reasonable profit for our efforts and
still bring him in at a lower cost than
that's what what needs to be done I mean
volume buying I don't think to stay once
again where we produce a lot of lumber
why don't we volume buy all the lumber
in the state and provide it at cost to
the builders that are building stick
build homes I mean there's a lot of
crazy ideas we can deal with but it's
all got to start with the changing of
the attitude and it's all going to start
with zoning and regulation
representative De Lorenzo uh thank you
Mr chair and thank you for your
presentation it's really um
exciting
um you know you mentioned the low income
housing tax credit program and that is
one of the
um
best programs for housing production the
thing is this a lot of um there are some
misnomers about the LA HTC program for
one
um
the rents aren't low
in order for a person to be able to
afford a housing tax credit apartment
they low-income people would need a
voucher because the
rents
um
at low income house tax float income
housing tax credit programs are the
fmr the
um
fair market rent
so therefore a person who is probably a
single person you know with kids would
not be able to afford
um Those runs without a voucher so I
feel like the program has been misnamed
and probably that's why you know
people NIMBY people sort of like back
away from the whole concept
so having used the program since 1988
and having developed close to a thousand
units with the program in partnership
with New Hampshire housing
I can tell you that your fmr
is driven by lack of housing
okay so what is what drives the fmr
supply and demand
so if the demand is high and the supply
is very low that allows landlords to
raise their rents if the supply was high
then rents would be a lot lower the more
Supply we can bring online the lower the
rents are going to get driven because
everybody wants a full unit and if
you're not going to if you think you're
going to hold it the rent above what
anybody can pay for it and still be able
to have your unit filled you're you're
barking up the wrong tree so fmr is
driven by supply and demand we're in a
situation where we have almost no Supply
and we have a very large demand so
that's what's driving that
the second thing with respect to the
light tech program is you have all
different levels they have 30 percent
median income you have 50 median income
you have 60 media income you have 80
median income and really there's some
programs that go up to 120 percent of
median income okay it's the median
income that that drives the rent okay
most of our subsidy or our subsidy is so
meager I think it's I know Ben Frost is
in the room and and he may be able to
Enlighten you a little bit more on the
limit but New Hampshire my last time my
check got under three million dollars
closer to two million dollars in lightak
okay two million dollars in my tech
isn't going to solve anything it's a
drop in the bucket when you consider a
project right now of 100 units is about
20 million dollars okay
to do a 20 million dollar light tech
project you're taking the entire State
subsidy to do 100 unit deal
so they have to be very very judicious
and they work on smaller projects and
more diverse Geographic areas to try and
cover the state which is their mandate
and large density projects don't really
get done well because there isn't enough
subsidy to drive them
same thing you guys have the
the fund and I appreciate that you guys
are trying to devote more and more money
to the affordable housing fund But there
again
construction costs are so high land
costs are so high land costs are so high
because of the regulation that we have
to develop on a single family house and
right now in New Hampshire
82 000 is added for just regulation
okay for us to go through the permitting
process and meet regulation
forget the land cost we've just spent
eighty two thousand dollars a unit
okay so when you figure the average lot
cost for a lot in New Hampshire right
now is well over a hundred thousand
dollars
we're 180 000 approaching 200 000 we
haven't built anything yet
okay we need to get those costs down
um on that question before I uh
are you able or your company can you
send us specific regulations that you're
dealing with that gets that 82 down I'd
like to look at those specifically
because maybe those are some things that
we can look at as a committee and then
the second thing is you mentioned
adopting a like when you adopt a
building to a current code when it's an
older building what is that
is there a specific part of the rsas
that we can look at that might classify
older buildings and loosen up the code
the code on that and you know new
development would have to follow the
code but maybe the older buildings like
you're talking about in Manchester
um conquered you know on the river those
kind of things like we could look at
that as a separate classification is
that classified separately or no
um yes all of that can be done the
information I have is old though last
time I addressed this Governor Benson
was in office and I think we adjust the
code issues in O3 so the information is
out there I just don't have it in my
disposal but think about this for a
second when I started developing real
estate in 1978 the obligation of a road
and utilities was on the municipality
fast forward to today that obligation to
build that road in those utilities are
on me so the only way I can get paid
back is by adding that cost to a housing
unit when I first started developing
real estate there was not no such thing
as an impact fee now there's an impact
fee for parks for the fire department
for the police department for the school
department and in some municipalities
that rises between 10 in one
municipality I can tell you in the
northern part of our state I paid twenty
four thousand dollars per unit to the
town as a fee for impact fees for one
apartment unit okay there are towns that
I work in right now for one residential
unit that are approaching twelve
thousand dollars
so and now you get the land cost you've
got your development cost of eighty
thousand you get an impact fee on top of
that okay those are the kinds of things
that have driven the cost of housing out
of sight now I've got to build my road
I've got to bring my utilities
by the time I get around to building a
single family house on some of these
lots I'm three hundred thousand dollars
in
okay I don't know how I would produce
something that was going to
be achievable for someone making fifty
thousand dollars a year which used to be
a very large sum of money in New
Hampshire for wages but that's a
thousand dollars a week no one making a
thousand dollars a week is going to get
a home from me when my cost before I've
even built the structures three hundred
thousand dollars that's why developers
moved to the I don't wanna
use the cliche of the mcmansions
the bedford's the wyndhams all of those
mcmansions all of the developers moved
to those areas because the regulations
drove the cost of the house High
when you were still dealing with a
high-end buyer you could still make a
reasonable profit
we've got to make it so that the
developer comes back to the
the local municipalities and still be
able to make a reasonable profit on what
he builds and that takes away the desire
to build mcmansions
the other thing is with those costs that
I've been mentioning at three hundred
thousand dollars or 200 000 into a lot
before you build a house you have to
build a mcmansion to make a buck
and I'm sorry I didn't directly answer
your question representative chair
um all of that information is out there
but my information is dated we would
need to have conduct a study currently
to bring all that information up to date
okay
um representative Walsh
thank you Mr chair and thanks for taking
my question getting back to the
Innovative solution with the water
curtain that you had redoing that old
building
I assume it's the ahjs that are
unwilling to come to compromise and
solutions and they just want to go
strictly by the fire codes
who came up with the water curtain idea
uh I'm just what I'm seeking for is a
way to to maybe encourage some of this I
came up with the water curtain idea the
chief of of fire in Manchester thought
it was Innovative and he made
our presentation to the fire marshal at
the state in order to get it approved
okay so we sold local municipality but
you know our codes will are fraught with
you need to do it this way
into the
um
and at the discussion of the local
building official
so you could all be local building
officials and I assure you if you read
one of the regulations each one of you
would have a different opinion on what
that regulation means
so when it's left up to the discretion
of the local building official or the
local Fire official
if that person is against you getting
your project done then it's interpreted
one way if he's in favor of you getting
your project done which is directly the
answer to your question then he'll make
an effort to figure out a way to achieve
it with you in this case fire chief was
Kane he went to the Fire Marshal's
office and said we think this is a good
idea let's try it and I got everybody to
buy in on the idea that the curtain
water was equally protective as the two
layers five base fire it
fire
um sheetrock and the engineer that was
hired even said that the water curtain
was better
it gave more protection because it was a
constant flow of water coming down to to
fight any threat okay whereas the
sheetrock still Burns it just burns at a
slower rate
um represent McConkey
uh thank you chairman Alexander and
thank you sir for being here
a lot of we keep hearing that you know
Water and Sewer is is a must my question
is if density in the rural areas was
sufficient your 5 000 square foot or
smaller lots have you or would you
consider some sort of centralized water
and or sewer speaking of the state
doesn't regulate if you're up to nine
users on one well and and some sort of
septic for X number of units have you
ever considered that or would that be a
non-starter for you no I've actually
built it so there's been a significant
innovation in septic systems okay where
they're rechargeable now
um
their designed for smaller areas
in Rochester New Hampshire I have a
septic system that's Services 204
Apartments
okay so yes the answer to the question
is you can get there
again can you afford it as a result of
all of the other things to the
development process that you're paying
for if you if those things went away
then yes you could afford
the
um
I call it hyperactive the hyperactic
septic where everything gets eaten
quicker and
um you have multiple Chambers and it's
cleaned and that sort of thing with
respect to the Wells I have my own Water
Systems I am a water system supplier
regulated by
um Des as a result of supplying water to
multi units yes that's all achievable
but you still got to build your water
system and you still got a dig your
Trulia one or two or three Wells for
your project those costs added on to the
cost of the development that we go
through and lack of density that we have
makes it cost prohibitive to do okay so
if some were to give somewhere you could
still meet the demand in the rural areas
by having the ability to do exactly what
you said provide your own water in in
septic okay but it comes at a cost and
somewhere along the food chain the cost
needs to give so if I'm going to be in a
rural area and I'm going to put in the
special septic and in my own water
system then I still need to
be able to achieve
the cash flow in order to do that and
currently the only way I do that is by
increasing the rent or increasing the
sales cost of the house
if I didn't have all of the over
regulation here and the impact fees and
had to build the road and do everything
else I could then afford
the septic and the well so it all comes
back down to to this is strictly a
financial exercise truly is what it is
okay it's what does it cost the
developer to produce the unit and what
can we get what impediment can we take
out of his way to reduce that cost to
therefore reduce the cost of the housing
if I could just follow up yep uh what's
your economy of scale how how large does
a project have to be for you to consider
it is it 20 units 50 200 units well let
me pose it to you this way you put the
same amount of effort into 100 unit
project as you put into a 10 unit
project because when you go to the
planning board it's the same site plan
it's the same calculations it's the same
drainage it's the same everything
the only thing I can tell you that costs
saved there is the scale makes your
engineering costs a little bit less but
other than that you're putting forth all
the same effort so if you're going to
put forth that effort then you naturally
want to try and put it forth on the
largest project you can get so that you
can get the best bang for your buck but
I have developed single families I've
developed two families I've developed
four families five families eight
families 20 families 20 unit buildings
50 and right now my company doesn't look
at a project unless it's 100 units or
more okay because it's the only way that
I can be certain that a company of my
size can still make a profit
thank you okay we're working on wrapping
this up but representative Damon then
representative Reed representative Walsh
thank you thank you
so you mentioned I think you said a 204
unit
project that you did in Rochester that
you put in the septic and so forth so
could you just expand on how did that
work financially based on what you just
said what were the trade-offs that made
it feasible so our Entry Road
or the main entry to our project is Town
Road for the first hundred feet
after that internally the town allowed
us to build our internal roads and keep
them private at significantly less
specification than what the Town Road
would normally have been Town Road
wanted 28 feet wide four foot shoulders
on each side enclosed drainage six
inches bituminous based two inch
bituminous top uh 18 and 6 box which
means the gravel sizes that go in it
that sort of thing when we went to build
our interior roads they were literally
35 percent of the cost of a Town Road
so with the savings of the cost of the
roadways we were able to justify the
cost of the advanced septic systems
who what
who's responsible for the cost of
maintaining those moderately the town is
the first hundred feet where the school
children are picked up and that sort of
thing and we maintain the inside but the
way we were able to design it
representative was our parking lots
right off of all of those interior roads
so they're when you go to powder parking
lot it isn't much more effort to plow an
extra 100 or 200 feet of roadway that's
leading up to it okay so we were able to
to design integrate the roadways as if
they were part of our parking lot system
okay um representative Reed
thank you and I just want to apologize
for missing the first part of your
testimony I'm moving much slower than I
would like to today
um I appreciated what I did here and I
appreciate the the concept or hearing
the concept
um uh reinforce that so much is
dependent on the the internal Town
politics and personalities whether a
project is difficult or easy just you
know whether those individuals happen to
like it or not in their individual
biases and that's not at all
standardized across the state my
question for you is the impact fees and
other fees that you uh spoke of isn't it
true that those are one-time fees
um yes their one-time fees and follow up
Mr chair
so it's fair to say that while those
affect the cost of housing for new
developments that impact fees don't at
all explain the explosion in the cost of
housing for pre-existing structures
that's just one component of it but
think about it this way if impact
feasible end time fee and it's 25 000
per unit the developer still needs to
pay that over his 20-year mortgage so
he's paying interest on that impact me
and he's paying it back principal a
little bit at a time so yes it's a
one-time fee up front at a town but
realistically we're paying for it for
the next 20 or 25 years
um and and I'm obviously including in my
statement
structures that are 100 years old or
more that these structures have been in
place before impact fees even existed
and yet we see an increase in the cost
of that housing as well so while I
understand that this is a true cost for
new developments I'm confirming it's
that is only impacting new developments
and there are other factors that work
for the rest of the housing market
thank you
thank you um representative Walsh thank
you Mr chair thanks one last question on
impact fees again I thought only about
14 towns imposed impact fees do you know
that to be true
I don't have that information in my
disposal but I it's not many I don't
believe I've developed in more than 14
jurisdictions and I know that I've paid
more than
impact fees in each place that I've gone
so if I follow up so the question I had
is assuming the number is still small I
thought it was 14 it might be more
um do the towns that don't have impact
fees
seek additional money for their impacts
like more expensive building permits for
example
or do you think the towns that have
impact fees are merely using them as a
as a deterrent
um
we're extracted funds are extracted from
us in a number of different ways let me
give you for instance we built where we
had water and sewer one time
and they town did an assessment where
they came and they said that
our sewer pump system won't accept your
sewage because it's not big enough
so we ended up building a second pump
house with a full second pump to the
tune of three hundred thousand dollars
which naturally was at our cost which
was then added to the cost of the
housing
whereas the town knew in advance that we
weren't going to be able to add
additional sewage to it because they
were already having problems and it
didn't accommodate what they were
already putting into it but we solved
their problem for them by putting in a
whole nother pump which solved their
initial problem not having to pay for it
and
um now they've got a brand new one as
well the amount of effluent that we put
into the new pump system that they put
in was less than one percent of the
capacity of the pump station we were
forced to build
Okay so
you know I've been doing this 40 years
I'm on the downhill slide you know it
used to be I wouldn't come here and
testify as it was out to the fact that I
had to continuously deal with the towns
at this point forward it doesn't really
make a difference to me what they think
because what I'm here to testify to is
it's a rightful or it's a right of every
New Hampshire resident to have a clean
affordable house to live in that they
can afford
okay and I was developing affordable
housing when other people were
developing mcmansions and I wasn't
making anything doing it it was right
for my employees it was right for the
general public it was right for my
municipality I lived in to get some of
this stuff done that attitude doesn't
exist anymore
if you look at the development Community
we're aging out
there aren't a lot of new developers
coming online you know why because they
can't make a profit doing this and it's
such an artist process to get through
people ask me why I don't sell them I
don't sell them is because I put so much
work on them because they become like a
part of me like my children I wouldn't
sell my children I don't want to sell my
projects either I had to go through all
this time and effort to get there
I'm keeping them I mean the development
processes in there's women in the room
and this is in a slight but anyway it's
like being pregnant okay
development you go through a lot of fun
trying to get it up and operating and
made okay just like you have a lot of
fun preparing for a baby
then you go through the nine months of
carrying the child and that's your
development process and it gets worse
and it gets worse and it gets worse and
it gets worse until you actually have
the baby and then you forget everything
that you went through because the baby
is so charming and wonderful and you go
back and you decide to do it again okay
well developing and building is like
going through pregnancy and labor okay
and then once the child is born and you
see how good the job you did you want to
go back and do it again that's the
development World in a nutshell
is quite the analogy I never thought
about that
but I'm going to use that or so thank
you if that's okay all right well I I
want to thank you for presenting to us I
think it's been very helpful and um if
the committee has questions we reach out
please you can reach out to me anytime
and be happy to come back I'd be happy
to take a call individually or provide
you with any information I can
appreciate it thank you very much
I'm gonna take a break well yeah let's
take a three minute break and then we'll
hear from the Community Loan Fund
all right we are getting started I'm
hoping the committee will come back to
their chairs
foreign
who I've known for many many years and
uh Sarah Merchant from the Community
Loan Fund thank you for coming
um thank you thank you Mr chairman and
I'd also just like to identify in the
audience we have some folks here in case
people have other questions uh after the
fact and it is from our Communications
and marketing
um division uh Steve varnum and Katie
McQuaid and from our Rock NH the
resident owned community staff uh
Jeannie Oliver and Kelly ciccarelli all
really smart people with a lot of
information that we can rely on as a
resource when you're doing your work so
in light of New Hampshire housing's
report on the deficit of housing stock
here in New Hampshire we are really
pleased to be before the community the
committee to tell you about an
overlooked housing sector that
represents seven percent of the um of
the affordable housing in or the housing
in the state of New Hampshire it's
affordable housing it's home ownership
and its wealth building and it's
manufactured housing manufactured
housing that sits in a community that
the residents own the land underneath
and that's a distinguishing factor of
that unfortunately this housing sector
is not overlooked by private Equity
investors from out of state who have
made a huge push in the state of New
Hampshire over I'd say probably the last
five years at least to buy up uh
communities and you'll see a little
further in this presentation what
happens when that happens can I just
interrupt for one second so if you look
at the folders in the desk in front of
you we do have a slide presentation and
the individual slides are available
right inside there so we can walk
through it together
thank you thank you thank you sir I
appreciate that so so far you've only uh
missed the cover sheet so
um one of the cool things about this is
that this is a really homegrown solution
New Hampshire created this solution the
legislature back in the 1980s made
manufactured housing real estate which
isn't common necessarily across the
United States and you also created an
opportunity to purchase law that's
existed in New Hampshire since the 1980s
and is slowly happening across the
United States and that opportunity to
purchase just means and representative
McConkey can weigh in here if he wants
he has a lot of knowledge about this
that if the park goes up for sale and
there's a purchase and sale the
residents get to match that purchase and
sale price wise time wise condition wise
no no reduced benefit for the seller
selling but the residents have to
participate in a commercially reasonable
sale in order to by that Community
there is one of the real bonuses to that
opportunity to purchase law is it
prevents a park closure which does
happen the land is bought residents are
given 18 months to move their homes and
um
that is not pretty uh this third slide
in your um in your packet is a picture
of a woman named Joe Hayes who watched
as her neighbors in Hooksett New
Hampshire at a community called Park
Place had their homes
um scooped up by an excavator and put
into a dumpster because they couldn't
afford to move those homes if they were
even movable that's why we don't call
them mobile homes anymore they're
manufactured homes by Statute here in
fact this happened probably 20 years ago
the site in Hooksett still exists with
nothing on it so these people all were
dislocated uh none of them actually
um ended up keeping their most of them
did not keep their homes and there's
nothing there since but we will look at
the resident ownership in the
affordability into perpetuity and
contrast this with an investor-owned
Park in the upcoming slides so
um resident owned communities as I
mentioned Community Loan Fund kind of
pioneered this concept starting in
Meredith with a little Community there
back in the 1980s and you'll see in your
packet also a nationwide slide this has
spread across the nation there are 146
resident owned communities in New
Hampshire right now that represents
almost 9 000 affordable housing
households that have been preserved here
in the in the state of New Hampshire and
we have a lot of partners that we've
worked with along the way to do that
lenders who have seen this as a really
great opportunity and all kinds of other
partners that have helped us improve uh
infrastructure
um
so in this structure that's created is
it's a consumer Cooperative that the
residents form it is a not-for-profit
corporation the residents still own
their house as they always have they
form the consumer Cooperative under RSA
301a and jointly by the land underneath
it so nobody owns a little square it's
not a condo where you own one forty
third of a piece or anything like that
the The Cooperative that corporation
owns that um that property they elect a
board they make their rules they set
their rent prices they have membership
criteria for who moves into that
community criminal background and credit
generally and the Community Loan Fund
stays with them we're not just a lender
to help facilitate that process but we
also provide them technical assistance
on how to run this new multi-million
dollar corporation that they own in fact
we stick with them for the 20-year life
of the own longer if they want through a
contract and we provide about 20 000
hours of technical assistance each year
to the communities
and so what is the manufactured home
just to make sure that we're all
starting from the same place a
manufactured home is defined by State
Statute and they have a HUD set building
code so Housing and Urban Development
code they're not modular and they're not
mobile they come in on a chassis they
are delivered and then they are they are
zip tied not zip tied they are tied down
in place and they are very expensive to
move once they are set in place they are
not meant to move this is a permanent
housing option and it's an asset
building home
it's the beauty of a resident owned
Community is you're also part of a park
you're part of a community and I do want
to mention Steve varnum who's part of
our Communications team is a member owns
a home in a manufactured home community
and is part of one of our rocks and so
he's also here to answer questions
directly about that but they are they
have a very high quality construction
that HUD code has been updated and since
the head code was put in place they are
not they are highly regulated they're
built inside of factories and the waste
in the process of building one
manufactured home that's in a 60 gallon
trash can so they are super efficient
ways of building a home and they are
constructed inside they're also
constructed to move and so they have to
be a very well constructed piece of
housing
um
and moving on so the next is there's 146
resident owned communities in New
Hampshire you can see on that map that
they are all over New Hampshire
um and a little over nine thousand about
nine thousand households has Tara had
said
it's important to note that we do income
surveys they are their income surveys
that the residents fill out when they go
through the process of converting to a
residential community in about 75 of the
residents who own homes and rocks have
make 80 percent of the area of median
income or less so these are truly an
affordable housing option
and they cover the entire breadth of New
Hampshire in addition this model has
been successful at preserving affordable
housing and the next slide shows you
that there are now resident owned
communities across the country out of
the New Hampshire Community Loan Fund
and the model set by the state of New
Hampshire and the legislature in our
60-day notice rule Rock USA was born
which has grown and it has about 150
communities Nationwide and growing as
well and so this is a model that has was
grown right here in New Hampshire and
that has spurned Innovation across the
country
so if you look at the next slide it's
Equity Exeter rock you can see some of
the size variation in our resident owned
communities this one in Exeter is almost
400 housing units and we have one
um not far from here that is our
smallest rock there's only four housing
units so they really cover the gamut of
sizes and styles and it definitely can
be some of the smaller models of housing
as we you were talking with your last
guest about
they're also um we tend to find that
they locate in different areas for
example in Exeter there's over 500 homes
in Resident owned communities spread
over five different resident owned
communities and in Rochester there's
almost 700 residential housing units in
Resident owned communities spread over
quite a number of them what I would like
to point out since you're asking
questions about zoning and regulations
earlier is that I believe in both of
these communities they most of these
were put in before zoning and it doesn't
mean that just because they're zoned
today and I think if you look at the
zoning map the areas that would allow
manufactured housing will be exactly
where they exist and the boundaries will
not be any larger than where this type
of housing currently exists and so
zoning is a big part of what we talk
about when we think about solutions to
the future of affordable housing so just
is that is that the biggest
impediment to this development or are
there other ones as well as far as new
development new development so I think
it um and I'll and I can touch a little
bit more on that so zoning is absolutely
an impediment New Hampshire again
um requires that all communities allow
for manufactured housing where a
single-family home is allowed much like
accessory dwelling units there's many
ways that you can say it's required but
you don't actually make it possible to
build and
um and that could be if you require two
acre zoning the affordability of a
manufactured home right it goes down
significantly if the state law also
defines a manufactured housing Parks but
it gives again communities the ability
to say if you want to build a
manufactured housing Park but you
require two acre zoning and you don't
allow for the density that makes it
affordable then new parks can't exist
today so zoning is a one of the
impediments I think for creating new
manufactured housing in Parks it's the
same cost of building a new road running
water and sewer or coming or putting in
well and septic and we have parks in
very rural areas on well and septic
systems but to do those new costs today
you have to spread that out over the
number of homes and it's the same math
that dick was doing and it is the same
problem the beauty of it is that I think
we have a pretty phenomenal model about
what density can look like but provides
an affordable option but those areas are
largely completely built out because we
only have the zoning to reflect what's
on the ground and it has been
eliminated or significantly reduced from
allowing these Eric these to be built in
the future there are I we know of one
that was recently built and I think or
approved probably the first one in over
20 years in Wolfeboro because there's
resident Community there that they've
seen the success with and they will
throw recently approve one as they need
affordable home ownership options we
also just heard that Litchfield might
have just approved a new one but again
these are the first in more than 20
years and highly highly rare
as an option thank you
um the next slide you'll see after the
Rochester one would very Cooperative in
Portsmouth does
um is is a good example of how we can
continue to make some progress with more
affordable housing there's probably 300
vacant Lots in rocks on Statewide and
because they're already approved parks
and the density is already approved a
home can be replaced so as an older
pre-1970 model home which wasn't built
to the specifications they are now it
fails it can we can put a new home in
there this Woodbury Cooperative slide in
here that was true in Woodbury there
were some um deserted wooden buildings
there and some homes that needed to be
removed we just are in the process of
putting six homes in here in downtown
Portsmouth radon Woodbury Ave improving
a lot of water infrastructure and um and
access for safety vehicles but this
represents a home you can Buy in
Portsmouth New Hampshire for less than
two hundred thousand dollars right now
which is pretty remarkable
um
let's talk about manufactured home
owners for just a minute that slide is
um uh in there next to the after the
Woodbury one just as dick antagnos was
just saying the people who live in these
manufactured housing parks are essential
workers they're people you see every day
they're people that you work with and
and it caters to a certain a certain
population other than that income level
of it being an affordable house as you
can see on the slide the statistics for
people who are 65 and older high school
education veterans and disabled it is a
smartly designed one-story home that you
can get in and out of very easy to ramp
so it makes sense for all of those
purposes but people from all walks of
life live in manufactured housing here
in Loudon New Hampshire a former police
officer is the president of that
Association there we have three
different communities where the town tax
collector lives in there in that
Community their nursing home employees
nurses at nursing homes teaches exactly
as you heard and it's not surprising
that it is not only affordable but it's
a it's a smart floor plan so let's just
look a little bit more at the
affordability we just mentioned what you
could buy a house in Portsmouth for this
is the most affordable housing option in
New Hampshire whether it's rental or
home ownership in fact it's easier it's
cheaper to live in manufactured housing
that you're buying that it is to rent
the comparable two-bedroom apartment in
the same area this first slide here just
shows you what rents um the difference
between the payments in various parts of
New Hampshire for a mortgage payment for
a conventional home renting an apartment
and they um manufactured home the next
one the next slide manufactured home in
a rock that shows you a recent home just
bought in Guilford New Hampshire the
purchase price there are um for this
income level of buyer lots of homeowner
Assistance programs and housing loan
trust money that can help with a down
payment for the house and this is an
actual transaction it includes the
mortgage payment the taxes the insurance
and the monthly lot rent you see which
is 325 down near the bottom the total
monthly housing cost for this home is
um 1257 this is a two bedroom two
bathroom that the owner is going to
Bill's wealth build equity in and at
some point sell that
um it in the bedrooms are on each end of
the home so it really works out well for
a parent and children or even roommates
in this it's a it's a really great
layout
um the next slide I'm sorry these are
two bedrooms that's a two bedroom that
specifically was one you can get up to
four bedrooms they go as small as one
bedroom and up to four bedrooms okay so
this is this this one that we're looking
at is the two bedroom unit okay it's a
two bedroom home two bedroom two bath
and that's pretty consistent these
prices like Statewide yeah the the ones
at Fort Smith uh we only had room for
one two bedroom home the others are one
bedroom there that one will be a little
uh less expensive than the two bedroom
one there uh the next slide on the
average new home sales price we don't we
don't need to tell you that I'm sure
this committee has heard the average
price of a single family home in New
Hampshire is um is way over 400 000 now
and that's a monthly mortgage payment of
about
3151 the average price of a manufactured
home 123 200 and that's gone up just
recently with the uh with the market
that's happening so manufactured home
savings on average compared to renting
um about 320 three dollars less per
month about thirty eight hundred and
seventy six dollars uh a year
and um I think we're gonna switch over
so I'll jump in here so um you're
looking at a graph with a huge blue
swath on the next page
um this is a study done by Rock USA
which does include New Hampshire
communities I said well and it looks at
the change in cost over time that
they've seen from an investor-owned
Community versus a resident owned
community in lot increases lot rent
increase and on average nationally we're
looking at just under a four percent
increase in lot rent over year over year
in an investor-owned community and it's
less than one percent in a resident
owned community so if you flip to the
next page what does that mean right
that's not the easiest chart to read so
the benefits of home ownership is after
10 years of living in a resident-owned
community on average your rent will be a
hundred dollars a month less than in an
investor community and that's a national
average
um if you've flipped to the next page
it's twelve hundred dollars a year every
year in rent being less and you can
really see that difference we do in the
next page talk about
how residents are really working
together to buy their parks and to save
them from investor type ownership where
they're they just don't have the same
option and control over their rent you
can understand why these would be
attractive to large hedge funds and
investor owners because if they're not
concerned about affordable housing and
asset building they can come in and
raise rent and they can raise rent and
there's little that the average
homeowner can do in an investor-owned
community and so the next shows an
article from The New Yorker this has
been acknowledged nationally as a
growing problem that and about a third
of
um manufactured
form communities across the country
since 2015 have been bought by large
investor buyers so fewer and fewer are
owned by our local Mom and Pops we still
have some here in New Hampshire and and
while the resident owned communities
movement is growing it is going to take
a lot of work to really secure these
types of affordable housing in
perpetuity
looking at maintaining affordability a
recent article in the Laconia Daily Sun
right here in New Hampshire is talking
about an investor-owned community in um
in called Great Brook and in Belmont
thank you so great book excuse me Great
Brook in Belmont
um and here's some quotes directly from
that newspaper article somebody was
buying a home in this park when they
signed they agreed to buy a home the lot
rent was 6 18 by the time they closed 30
days later the lot rent had increased to
691 and they just got another notice
that the lot run is going up to 746. so
in an investor-owned Community that's
over a hundred and thirty dollar
increase in less than a year and that's
the reality of what can happen in
investor-owned communities in New
Hampshire or anywhere and so that's why
the resident owned Community model is so
strong because the residents vote when
to increase their rent and those
increases go based on infrastructure
improvements right based on actual costs
that the board and the residents are
holding themselves responsible to
um so lastly the takeaways that we want
you um to take away from this
presentation is manufactured housing is
the most affordable housing option in
New Hampshire renting or owning it is
the lower of any of those uh options
um New Hampshire Community Loan funds
Park conversion and mortgage programs we
Finance those homes that people are
buying there is a really important part
of the affordable housing solution here
in the state of New Hampshire and we've
been doing this for 40 years now and
have gone from needless to say a hundred
communities in the early 2000s quickly
to 146 today with three more in the
queue right now we still have plenty of
work to do not just in the residents
interested in acquiring their Parks but
in helping them maintain the parks and
um and the technical assistance that we
provide we're really grateful for the
Forward Thinking of the New Hampshire
legislature back then but it's really
something that we need to protect it's
not something that we take for granted
the opportunity to purchase law there
have been efforts to lessen the ability
of the residents to take advantage of
that right especially over the last
couple of years so we really need to
protect and enhance those laws
and last takeaway the resident owned
communities provide housing stability
but they also and they are not dependent
on any state or local funding right so
this is true affordable home ownership
that is naturally occurring across the
state
um and that there's very very few
opportunities for home ownership
affordability that does not require
subsidy
um in large part
we do think zoning is a key part of the
future here we need more resident owned
communities we would love to see new
communities built with new housing like
in Portsmouth bringing in brand new
homes into communities is is incredibly
important and it uplifts the communities
these models not only Empower people to
be able to learn a lot of the leadership
skills and the skills about running it's
essentially almost like a small
municipality right I mean you have a
Capital Improvements plan you have
infrastructure improvements you're
navigating all of this it teaches real
skills that people are using to grow
themselves and to be a better part of
our community and economy going forward
but we do
we do have factors that prohibit new
communities from being formed or even
existing communities that we have that
have land from expanding and a lot of
that has to do with minimum lot sizes
parking requirements
um and and other barriers within
communities just like nimbyism any type
of housing we fight nimbyism here in New
Hampshire but that is certainly a
problem with our resident owned
communities and the creation of new
affordable home ownership options
and with that um we do have some
Partners in the room I'd just like to
acknowledge too New Hampshire housing
makes a huge part of our welcome home
loan team contributions as well they
provide some of the down payment
assistance that Tara mentioned and cdfa
and some of the other partners across
the state with infrastructure
improvements to our resident owned
communities
thank you very much I'd love to get um
specific I know this I would like to get
specific
um barriers that are put in place by
municipalities like you mentioned Park
but I'd like to get kind of a list of
those things so we can look at that of
course absolutely I'd also Point um we
can also point you to the new New
Hampshire zoning Atlas project you can
see right on there there's a toggle for
manufactured homes and manufactured
where they can be built and you'd be
it's less than 10 that allows
manufactured homes on small Lots great
okay we're gonna go around so represent
Walsh
thank you Mr chair
thanks for coming and thanks for the
presentation uh full disclosure I love
manufactured homes I used to live for a
short period in Country Lane Manor in
Candia mom and pop but it was great I
wish I had never left I made the mistake
of buying a house
um but my name is Thomas Welsh from
Hooksett
and up until three weeks ago I was the
chairman on the planning board so if
you're going to use Hooksett as a
horrific example I just want to clarify
exactly what happened it was only about
six to eight years ago actually
and the park had been there since I can
remember and I'm almost 60. it was
beyond blighted it was actually
condemnable but the town never did
anything to those people we have no
issue with them no no it wasn't that
town a developer came in out of state
developer
and wanted to put up two apartment
buildings we said fine we know the
people can't afford the place are you
going to give us a guarantee that they
have an option for these affordable
apartments and they said yes
I said did we say the only other thing
we want is right on Route 3 that's our
commercial District give us a couple
we'll give you the mix used you can do
your two buildings just reserve some
some modest commercial on Route 3 itself
they ignored us they came back with
three giant buildings with underground
parking and everything else and that's
and then and when we said no that's not
what we asked you and they never came
back we were not the deterrents we were
actually trying to help that area
just to be clear uh those people also
had 18 months it's unfortunate that it
had to happen but state law gives them
18 months to find other other uh
places to live and you are correct none
of those would have survived going over
the road that's just a situation we're
in so again
I have to defend my town when I see it
being used as a horrific example of
something really mean it's not how it
happened
I do have one question though Mr chair
if I can yes question
um I Heard recently the EPA is also
going to be increasing the the
requirements of Energy Efficiency in
mobile homes
do you have you heard of that and do you
know how much that's going to increase
the price of them I don't think it's
necessary but what say you so there have
been proposals and they're it's open for
comment right now
the the current manufactured housing is
a far cry from the older manufactured
housing but I I don't think the public
is generally well educated about what
the quality of manufactured housing is
we have been doing some
um investigating of if in fact there are
requirements or funds available about
heat pumps and things like that to keep
people from relying on kerosene and
things like that from the heating so
lots of room for improvement here in New
Hampshire where we're really focused I
haven't I don't think the change to
efficiency standards has got much legs
now but it's hard to tell from a comment
period the manufactured housing industry
and the Builders of manufactured housing
Clayton Homes have a very strong
presence and they're actually a
wonderful manufacturer they're doing a
lot of innovative things with their
homes down so we're watching it we're
aware of it but so far we're trying to
figure out what works best for New
Hampshire
go ahead yeah I'm just concerned because
obviously it defeats the purpose if the
price of this thing keeps climbing
um just for while you're watching it too
heat pumps in New Hampshire yeah not
always what they're cut out to be once
it gets below 20 degrees so you know
thank you
representative Gibbs
thank you Mr chairman
um and uh welcome to the committee thank
you for coming uh
I'm also on the Commerce Committee
um and a few weeks ago uh there was a
bill before the Commerce Committee on a
complaint process for the residents of
mobile uh sorry manufactured housing
parks
um I think I said earlier I I worked for
HUD for 29 years and they changed the
statute from a statute on mobile homes
to a statute on manufactured housing and
we all had to correct our terminology
but our tongues don't always cooperate
uh anyway
um uh a resident of a resident owned
Park
um uh testified before the Commerce
Committee very very upset almost in
tears
um about problems she and some of the
other residents were having with the
management of the resident owned Park
and particularly how they were handling
the parks funds
um and as I understand it they had a
loan from the New Hampshire Community
Loan Fund
um but she was very dissatisfied
um with the technical assistance that
was being provided now the Commerce
Committee has a lot of builds and I
don't have all the details uh memorized
I was just trying to find my notes
um
on that on that hearing but I actually
don't think I have them with me
um uh but she was saying essentially
that
um she thought that they would get
assistance from the Community Loan Fund
but that they weren't getting the
assistance that she expected now it
seemed um and again I don't have all the
details in my head that in fact
um the uh the bill really wasn't
necessary because there is an existing
uh complaint board for for residents of
manufactured housing Parks
um but my question is
um uh have you heard anything about that
testimony I don't know if there was
anybody from the Community Loan Fund at
that hearing
um and can you tell us how the Community
Loan Fund deals with complaints that you
receive
um thank you representative Gibbs I was
here I was present for that um that
hearing and that same person has
testified in in several other
um hearings with those complaints
um we work a lot with the board of that
community that person isn't a member of
the board as a matter of fact they've
been in existence since 2019 and we've
spent just shy of 8 000 hours of
technical assistance with that Community
um dealing with a succession of three
different boards uh Each of which
thought the other one did a crappy job
of running the community so we are
working through that that individual
contacts uh attends the the monthly
board meetings and there's a time for
questions at the end and sometimes the
answers aren't what that person is
hoping so we we work with the boards the
governance of those Community we really
don't work with referring individual
members
um disputes between members but the bill
that you're referring to the um that
would either save the manufactured
housing board that exists or create a
new one which is another possibility
that the Commerce Committee has looked
at we have been involved with that and
would are willing to work with them to
make sure there's something in place for
residents that can't necessarily go to
court to fix these disputes each time so
well aware of it and um and um did
listen to that testimony
thank you thank you
representative Reed
thank you
um so aside from and I'm sure with every
human undertaking there's going to be
problems and and conflict and so I don't
know anything about the issues except to
say I'm sure that there always are
issues but on a much broader level I
just want to thank you for everything
that you do
um because as a committee when we talk
about housing in general we tend to
focus I I think too much on rental
housing and truly truly what we really
want is home ownership and an affordable
home ownership because home ownership
not only I think we talk about NIMBY
exclusionary zoning the purpose of which
is to kind of if I may be so blunt to
kind of keep certain types of people out
maybe income level people and really
what we end up doing is having a high
rent housing
that makes our communities more unstable
which is worse than if we had had stable
lower income people who owns their homes
and I think homeownership is such a key
level of Liberty and freedom for people
in the the uh underpinning of our entire
economy so um having said all that thank
you for for uh being like I think the
primary force for affordable home
ownership
um is it yes sir there is yes Mr chair
is it fair to say that the thing that
got you started the thing that enabled
this to happen was that original uh law
passing in the 80s the 60-day notice
um which is not a right of first refusal
but a consider this offer fairly law
correct correct and if I may just
quickly follow up across the country
there have been
um especially recently because of
housing costs across the country
um a bunch of co-ops that are not
manufactured housing but multi-family
housing Etc I understand this is not
your area of expertise in fact you all
helped me when I reached out to you last
summer when I had a multi-family uh
house in my district that wanted to go
Co-op but is it also fair to say that if
we extended something similar to that to
multi-family housing not just
manufactured housing that there would be
possibilities I know there's differences
between manufacture housing parks and
multi-family housing but there would be
possibilities to increase homeownership
affordable home ownership for
multi-family housing structures as well
um we we have we have a model that works
for sure it's been tried and tested we
have lots of templates and processes and
policies and things like that
um we would be more than happy to have a
discussion about is that transferable to
multi-family and what needs to be
tweaked to make that happen we we agree
that this is smart home ownership for
people at a level that they can afford
and be would be glad to see that that
model spread thank you and I'll just
have those conversations with you later
I think I'd like to add one of the
things again that makes this affordable
and both of those models I'm just going
to go back to its density
and and I just want to underscore how
incredibly important it is in this being
an affordable home ownership model and
other affordable ownership models
you're all set 100 all right great
okay great
representative thank you I actually have
a question without a long intro
um thank you
so your your uh goal is to create these
um opportunities for these people to buy
these
um these Parks
um how do you have any numbers on how
successful you have been like what are
the number of parks that have been sold
versus the number of parks that have
been sold into this kind of like home
like the owner occupied kind of a thing
and so like is it 10 or 50 how
successful have you been so it is a
great question we've been at it for 40
years we think there's 450 parks
thereabout in the state of New Hampshire
146 of them a resident owned community
so so far one third of them are resident
owned but we work with a lot of groups
or several groups yearly sometimes they
decide they don't want to be resident
owned they would rather have somebody
else doing all the work and paying the
bills and not meeting us a board and
um sometimes so that's one reason why we
work with somebody and they don't do it
the residents just vote against it
another reason is the private Equity
money that we see come into the state
that just will pay obscene amounts for
um for these Parks we worked with a
community in Rochester this year that
the purchase price for the 300 there's
about 325 homes existing development
rates for more there but the purchase
price was 58 million dollars and that is
just Way Beyond The Pale a residents
rent would have gone from 500 something
to 900 a month in order to do that and
private Equity money can afford to come
and do that and unfortunately those
people will have nine dollar 900 lot
rents at some point but it's just not a
level that we can we can compete on and
we don't have a solution for that right
now people that are just willing so
that's a purchase price that went up to
110 a unit uh it's got to be far before
below that I think the most expensive
we've done is 80 000 a unit uh this thus
far so
some some of those may come up for sale
again and the residents get another
chance at it
um we don't know but we every one that
we know of that comes up
um we work with the residents to give
them the option to do it and it's it's
more than half I think that we work with
that actually become resident owned
communities
representative Waltz thank you Mr chair
uh could you speak to um I believe
you're involved in the um Danville Four
Seasons conversion a few years ago and
also in my town is cotton Farms so we've
got the two opposite sides of the
Spectrum which representative yukela
does also represent as well could you
share with your involvement in those
yeah a great great story and uh story
um the the great story is uh Danville
Four Seasons we uh they picked the name
Rock Rimmon as What the residents call
them uh were approached to by their
Community a matching purchase and sale
that was too high for them to afford and
we actually had to say no the first time
and they were they were really really
upset about that it came back a year
later that sale never went through so
maybe it wasn't even a real purchase and
say oh we don't know it came back at
half the price the next year I think it
was actually two million dollars the
residents were really excited about that
not only did they buy their Community
they've done water and sewer and Paving
and done unbelievably great things to
the community which was formerly a
campground at one point and a couple of
years ago we did a project with Harbor
homes in Nashua put in 10 500 square
foot homes that are all now occupied
with formerly homeless veterans uh who
now have their own Community within this
community and that is a bunch of really
hard-working people uh that have made an
incredible little Community uh for
themselves there and that's the huge
success story cotton Farm Village also
in Danville
manufactured housing Park uh that had
some extra land uh there were some
attempts for the residents to buy it a
few a lot of years ago that fell through
but since that time two big apartment
buildings have also been located on that
same parcel to work with those groups we
would probably have to work with them
with a manufactured housing Park and
figure out another plan for the
apartment buildings but um that has an
investor owner that's from out of state
and we've tried to work with him because
the residents would like to buy it it's
not a great housing situation not only
does the rent continuously go up when
you get too far behind on your rent
sometimes that owner makes a deal with
you to just take your house and forget
the rent and my last check of the
registry of deeds six times
people had said okay I can't afford the
background I'll just walk away here's a
deed to the house and then the owner
subsequently just sells it to somebody
else so they've stripped those folks of
their um Equity that they had built up
in their homes
um it is uh it's a situation we would
love to work with if there was a
mechanism for us to work uh there's one
very hard-working individual in that
community that will will probably make
it resident owned I think before before
his final days and
um is really the caretaker of that
community so great Community they just
haven't got across the Finish Line yeah
representative Damon
I have too many questions try to be
concise
so you mentioned there being 300 vacant
I think
Lots across the state and then spoke
about upgrading the homes that some of
them are ones from before they were as
good equality so are there 300 vacant
that have nothing on them and then
additionally
the improving the quality yes that's
true
um so I would say there's homes that
there's lots that have been approved
that a home has never been installed on
and we have recently shifted our model a
bit to bring on and provide additional
technical assistance to those
communities that have multiple lots that
are vacant we are now helping them
because just like and it's really hard
for an average homeowner to figure out
how to do this as a co-op board that's a
whole nother level of commitment that a
volunteer has to do and so we're
providing technical assistance to those
communities to help them understand the
process of laying the slab and how do we
hook up water and sewer and how do we
get a new home located there and so that
is something that we're helping to
provide technical assistance on and we
are looking to help fill those as
affordable home options that come up for
sale on the General Market
and I think we probably will place 50
new homes for this either rehab or or
place 50 new homes this year but then we
convert more communities in the and
we're back up to 300 second Watts again
yeah and we also will help with those
ones that are vacant dilapidated to help
those communities unders go through the
process of the tax title and the deed
research and to take those homes to
demolish them and to place new homes
where they just have vacancy that's not
providing lot rent to the community
and when you spoke about density what is
the square footage lot that you would
consider to be ideal
I think it depends on the community and
all park or a range yeah so we have a
really uh lovely community that we work
with on Dover Point down near newicks
that actually has 18 homes on one acre
and it is it's a great little Community
there are other communities that look
like a subdivision of ranch houses
um
my house about three blocks away from
here sits on
um 5000 square feet just as dick was
talking about it's it's a it's you know
the the footprint of a manufactured home
it's the the same thing and and it's
plenty of space so I think that you know
the idea of putting eight on an acre is
is there's a lot of lawn to mow with
eight on an acre I also think it depends
on Water and Sewer um and we could show
you some examples and if you're looking
for hard data we could probably do some
quick analysis on density differences in
different parks with some photos that
wouldn't be too hard for us to provide
to you so that you can see what some of
those look like and some are based on
water and sewer and some have septic and
well right so those do make a little bit
of a difference and I do think it it's
different in Portsmouth where um I think
we have 18 home where we have 18 on one
acre sometimes it's 12 and um and
sometimes so there's it depends yeah can
I do one more Yep
so is 60 days enough notice for Park
residents to organize to make an offer
when a private Equity investor is coming
in that sounds really short to me it
feels really short when it's happening
um too we We Do It um we do it every
time
um we and that's to sign a purchase and
say oh a matching purchase a sale so if
in the informational session
residents aren't committing to buy the
park they're committing to do the
research to see if they want including
the purchase of sale which has all of
the conditions you would imagine with
financing and you know infrastructure
studies and things like that so we're
we're making it work with 60 days and
other laws we're seeing across the
country that have proposed to our 60
days also
yep
so separately from what you said and
this is just ever so helpful and
informative
are the homes being manufactured in New
Hampshire mostly or not
no I think it's a variety of things
there certainly are dealers there's
manufacturer home sales in New Hampshire
and so they're coming within New
Hampshire and there are New Hampshire
jobs on manufactured housing but they
are being manufactured all over
I think the closest uh facilities
manufacturing facilities to us now are
in New York and Pennsylvania
thank you very much okay representative
McConkey
thank you uh excuse me thank you again
Mr chairman
um ladies
um I talking about impediments I've been
in this business I've sold Parks
um
the the people that um that they they
have to be resin based to own a home in
there I can't remember
so you can't sub lease a home that's in
there
the
um
does it have to be a manufactured home
could it be a modular home
we um
the communities and they if they don't
have a loan with us they can make their
own rules but we advise manufactured
homes only because it keeps them within
the definition of a manufactured housing
Park which is how they get a lot of the
advantages of density and private roads
and and those kinds of advantages
shortlist here at the end of 20 years in
your financial obligation is done they
have the right to continue on
are can at the end of 20 years kid do
they have to remain a co-op forever
don't have remain a co-op forever but
the bylaws and the way they're
Incorporated because they are a
not-for-profit Cooperative means they
can't benefit if they sold that
Community okay they can pay off their
debt they can pay back the membership
fee but the rest of it goes to a
charitable like kind use through the
charitable trust in talking about
impediments uh the park that one of the
parks I'm familiar with if you were to
apply the Town's new standard for
manufactured home park where there are
four existing homes on this one property
a new property would only have one home
so average 3600 square feet works
perfectly well in good sand and soil
they
in the other so zoning zonings is a huge
issue how many of your 300 vacant Lots
had a dilapidated home that was either
not completely wasn't removed to the
point that the town would now release
the taxes on it is is that I I know of
several that still have rotting frames
sitting on the homes have been removed
I got to believe that that's an issue
for getting some of your Lots rented
was a Supreme Court case about five
years ago called Everett Ashton versus
the city of Concord that says when the
home is in that kind of non-inhabitable
state that the town can no longer
hold up the demo permit in exchange for
the payment of taxes they have to Abate
the taxes on it so that has made some
progress in getting rid of some but
communities especially the boards of
communities have got to do the work to
do that if it's a home that actually
still maybe has a title or an owner
there's a process they've they're
learning a lot about going through
probate for residents that died and just
walked away from the home and the family
is not interested so that's quite a
process to do but we do we do work with
communities on hiring an attorney and
getting that done so we can put a new
and I'm at my final question just
okay thank you for that you mentioned
Harbor Homes project and working with
some veterans and putting a number of
units was any of that done in existing
Co-op Parks yes uh Rock Rimmon in
Danville New Hampshire if at all
possible if you could send that along we
have a group of we have a group of
residents in Ossipee that's been working
on affordable housing we're working at
Carroll County on a project
and they've come asking questions so
thank you for that thank you
representative
thank you thank you for taking another
question
um you talked about
um possibly being able to give us some
density data on your
your existing kind of membership or
Parks or that you service or whatever
um
if you could
um separate out the parks that have
their own water as far as like the
density if they provide their own water
or if it's
um city water I would like to see those
density numbers split out specifically
um you know what is the density of
of you know Portsmouth versus the
density of one that has their own septic
and Sewer on on site because obviously
they're going to be less dense on those
thank you great
um right any other questions thank you
very much this is very helpful we
appreciate it I think I'm sold on these
things I think I want one myself so I
appreciate the help thank you
foreign so with that we're going to take
a lunch um we'll meet back here at one
o'clock we'll be here a presentation
from New Hampshire commissioner on human
rights so see you all at one
okay Welcome Back special committee on
housing
um I would like to welcome up next
um the Human Rights Commission
oh honey are you taking back seat
okay all right great
so thank you for coming I think we're
looking
um particularly at
um how housing intersects obviously with
um your commission and if improvements
any need to be made in that area thank
you
wait is it red is it red red is good
that's counter-intuitive isn't it okay
hi I am Sarah Burke Cohen I am the
assistant director at the New Hampshire
commission for human rights I am here to
talk with you a little bit of today
about
um what we do and our housing laws where
the intersection takes place so the New
Hampshire commission for human rights we
are the enforcement agency for RSA 354a
and since I know you all have the
statutory scheme memorized um the 354a
are the laws against discrimination in
New Hampshire
um so
um we do a couple of things right
um like I say we are the enforcement
agency we also are charged with
educating the community
doing Outreach talking with anybody who
will listen about discrimination and
ending it we cover a number of different
areas so we cover employment housing
public accommodation and public
education and I will tell you that there
is an intersection between housing and
public accommodation
um I'll talk to you a little bit about
that as I sort of go on just so that you
understand where things sort of
intersect
um we uh so the laws against
discrimination protect uh folks what we
call under protected classes in New
Hampshire the protected classes are age
and that's any age in housing so it
doesn't
um doesn't matter what age you are age
is protected
um sex which includes gender and
pregnancy sexual orientation gender
identity race color religion national
origin marital status disability and
then the housing Arena only familial
status familial status is if you have
children 18 years or younger living with
you that definitely becomes an important
thing in the housing area we do see a
number of cases where discrimination
takes place based on that familial
status I have sort of to back up for a
second I have a little bit of a unique
perspective when it comes to fair
housing
I work at the commission now I used to
work for a New Hampshire legal
assistance in their fair housing
um
uh programs so I sort of have seen it
sort of from representing clients to now
being the enforcement agency
um
I'm going to kind of skip our process
because I want to get to know what your
questions are so our process for
enforcement just briefly is
um we do everything at our agency okay
we do intake so people call us with
complaints we help them draft a charge
we investigate those complaints and we
can have a public hearing on those
complaints a public adjudicative hearing
to make a final decision we can award
damages on that complaint and Levy fines
um
so where I wanted to talk with you a
little bit about so housing
discrimination
um we obviously enforce the state
statute there are a few exceptions to
the state statute
um where I venture to say you can
actually discriminate
um uh as a landlord so let's talk about
those a little bit so
um housing discrimination Empire it
applies to all landlords except if you
are owner occupied in New Hampshire you
have to have three units or less you
have to live there
so you can't be oh I owner I'm owner
occupied but I live in the house next
door so you live in the property that
means you have you can
you can really decide who is renting
from you
the thought process behind that is that
it's your home because you're living
there and it's a small small enough
space that you're not you're sort of in
the market as a landlord but not really
in a big Market as a landlord housing
for the elderly
um that's what it's called in the
statute so
um that is senior housing there are
exceptions to our age discrimination
statute
um they're very specific on how they
work who can be include included who can
be excluded and how that works 55 plus
communities and then I think it's
60 plus 65 plus communities have some
different rules that are exempt from the
straight up age
discrimination in the statute
there are single-family homes if I own a
house and I sell it to to representative
Alexander and I don't use anybody to
help me sell it right I just do it
myself then I can choose who I sell that
to because I'm not in the business of
being a landlord okay and then one of
the other exceptions is housing operated
by sort of uh clubs or religious
organizations those are really you have
to be a member so the the real
um
definitions of those are parsonages
you know
religious facilities you know if you're
a priest and you're live someplace or a
monastery where you have to be a member
in order to be in that housing or uh
looked at for that housing
so let's talk a little bit about what's
prohibited right so what what do we have
that's prohibited what is sort of what
do we see that landlords can or are
doing right so it is treating people
differently right based on their
protected class hey we're only putting
um we are only renting allowing
um men to be in this building and women
have to be in this building that would
be treating people differently it can
also be other specific terms and
conditions
um more specific it can be steering
which is also differing treatment
steering is when what we see and have
seen in the past is
um landlords steering families with
children to specific units hey this unit
is maybe you have shiny building a and
and not so shiny Building B and we're
going to put all the families with
children in this other building and if
there's no units available then we're
not renting shiny building a to any
families with children kind of inhibits
right the ability for people to find
housing right if you're only renting to
specific people in specific buildings
there's also exclusionary zoning I
haven't seen a big exclusionary Zone in
case it case but I know they're out
there we haven't seen them at the
commission a lot of the exclusionary
zoning cases
um we don't have a current contract with
HUD have HUD will see those more than
than us right now
also of course there's straight up
refusal to rent I'm not renting to you
because of your race color national
origin or your religion or your
disability
it can be failing to provide a
reasonable accommodation or reasonable
modification if I come and try to rent
you and I have a wheelchair and I ask if
you can put uh you know some sort of
ramp on the building and you say no I'm
not renting to you because you have a
disability that becomes problematic and
potentially discriminatory we often see
the cases that come in for us are based
on disability and people requesting
reasonable accommodations and reasonable
modifications reasonable accommodations
are changes to the rules right changes
to the terms and conditions reasonable
modifications are changes to the the
facility the physical building itself I
need a pull bar in my bathroom can I can
I install it or can you install it
depending on who is funding who who the
um if the um landlord is getting federal
funds
so I wanted to talk with you a little
bit about where the intersection
um between
housing and public accommodation right
so housing clearly are residential right
residential units it's called in the
statute it is defined as a dwelling
right where somebody actually lives
right where the intersection happens is
public accommodation public
accommodation falls into falls into
place where you have homeless shelters
hotels those are considered places of
public accommodation which still fall
under RSA 354a where people can't
actually discriminate uh people trying
to go to those facilities based on their
race color national origin any of those
basis
um
so there is that intersection that
anybody that really is a housing
provider really falls under RSA 354a and
shouldn't be discriminating based on
those protected classes and a charge
could potentially be in front of us if
they're doing that
that's sort of my general what we do so
what are your questions what can I
answer
to you for you so my my first question
is
um
regarding
55 plus communities what
if there's no discrimination on age
and then there's communities that
require 55 plus what that looks like
legally I'm sure I know it's allowed but
I'm just trying to understand where that
comes from yeah and then
um
why haven't there been more
um more pushback when a community says
no to a development because it could
have the potential of having children in
it like as a as if that's used as a
specific finding effect in a refusal why
is that
is that allowed right okay okay so let's
take that apart um I think that's going
to be easier let's start with the 55
plus communities
I don't have it all right here but 55
um essentially what happens is you have
to be 55 or older right to apply for
this community
however I believe 80 percent of the
community has to be 55 plus and that
other 20 can be not 55 plus so let's
just say my spouse and I want to enter
into a 55 plus community and he's
45. we still can apply for that we can't
be denied just based on him being under
the age of 55. okay same goes with if
I'm living in a 55 plus community and
maybe I have to take custody of a
grandchild
um that grandchild can still be allowed
in the community because of
um because of the 80 20 split right they
still allow people under the age of 55
to be there so that's where the
community is you're exempt the community
exempt is exempt from the age
discrimination
um portion of RSA 354a as long as they
are following the specific rule so if
I'm 55 I apply but you deny me because
my husband is under the age of 55 that
could potentially be you know we could
be discriminatory because you're
discriminating you're not following the
rules when it comes to 55 plus Community
now I believe it's 60 or 65 plus has
different rules sort of the older people
get have different rules right because
you start getting into assisted living
care communities which really are only
for people who are a certain age or
older nursing homes Etc kind of fall
into that so then it can be a hundred
percent over the age of six State now
can you repeat your other question
because it's already it's in there but I
just want you to help me get it back to
the top yeah um we recently passed
language that says that when a um
a project is denied
there has to be specific findings of
fact and I guess
is one of those findings of fact
could could it be that
the project has the potential of having
many children
and pressure on the school district
would that be allowed as a finding a
fact to deny a project
and your interpretation of that well I
will tell you I mean so the commission
sort of
any case can be a charge right
um so in that case if the project is
found to be denied based on its impact
on the school district could someone
could an individual bring a charge could
uh I would say a town person bring a
charge I mean the answer to that is yes
they could be bring a charge I think
that
um you know
when it comes to cases in front of the
commission right so what would happen is
the towns person would bring a charge
hey this is being denied based on we
believe is exclusionary zoning right and
um the affirmative defense would be like
would be hey well this is going to
impact the tax basis is going to impact
and then the commission would make a
decision from there based on case law
based on you know statutory
interpretation can I tell you right now
what that decision would May would be no
because I'd need to really look at we we
need to look at the actual specifics and
the sort of that case by case basis and
look at it in terms of what other case
law is right out there right now and I'm
not
It's A New Concept I was just curious
yeah but I mean it would be it would be
something that would be chargeable I
mean that we would certainly investigate
based on that because the question is is
this you know is this is this
exclusionary zoning if we're saying hey
we're not we don't essentially we don't
want children here because it's going to
impact the taxes in the school district
it certainly could be brought okay thank
you um representative
thank you
um I have a real world thing happening
okay
um and it has been happening for uh well
over a year I think but
um it's actually a company that's that's
actually presented to this very
committee uh bought a retirement
community in my town and ever since then
they've had a whole bunch of issues
um multiple different issues but
specifically uh issues around
accessibility and one accessibility of
the general uh property
for everybody because there's a lot of
uh mobily impaired people there
obviously but also one particular person
who is missing one of her legs and
unable to use the shower or the bathtub
that was provided and we've asked for
accommodations to be made and they've
refused and I guess my question is uh
what does one do and how would you all
be able to help that situation
so you know again I'm not providing
legal advice that's not what we do and
um but I will take this as a
hypothetical that you're giving us and
certainly um requesting a regional that
would be a reasonable modification if
you're asking for something to be
changed in a facility it's a reasonable
modification now not knowing uh I'll
tell you a little bit about reasonable
modifications
generally speaking a landlord needs to
allow those to those to occur reasonable
modifications to occur unless there's
some sort of undue hardship right for
the landlord now what does that mean
well that means if I need a bar a new
tub
Etc or a handicap or a wheelchair ramp
that generally speaking the landlord has
to allow that certainly with a a
wheelchair ramp it has to do with um
making sure there's enough space Etc et
cetera now where it comes into play with
the reasonable modifications is who pays
for it right because a reasonable
modification if you are a landlord that
has is receiving no federal funds there
are specific federal funds maybe Meryl
can tell you so it's a Section 8 voucher
so those aren't necessarily considered
receiving federal funds that's the last
time I
um understood that that section 8
vouchers aren't you're getting federal
funds but you're not getting federal
funds at the same time this particular
structure was built with federal funds
when it was originally built and a new
person has has bought it but it's still
under that I believe so if it's under
that then reasonable modification wise
the landlord would um have to pay for
that modification right if it's not
considered if the federal funds used to
build the property or the federal funds
that they're still receiving for the
property aren't considered part of um
there is a list of specifically what is
um uh applicable then the person would
have to pay for the modification right
the individual would have to pay for
that modification
but at the end of the day it doesn't
sound like there's a reason why they
should be denying the modification right
because there are I mean there are other
agencies that will will help with sort
of modifications right when it comes to
people with disabilities so if a person
were to get denied that modification
right they have sort of a couple of ways
to go
um they can file a charge with us
certainly
um number one number two if they would
prefer they can file a charge with Hut
so we don't have a contract with them
we're working on getting a contract with
a HUD so that we can we can sort of work
together
that person should file a claim if the
landlord's not allowing that
modification to occur I would say that
that would be a chargeable uh claim
something that could be docketing uh Mr
chairman clarify
um so I did bring it's my fault because
I brought up her this one tenants
example very specifically but the
property in general
um the pavement lots of lots of barriers
to Wheelchairs and Walkers and such so
that it's difficult for them to navigate
the actual common property
um does that fall under accessibility
ability and so you know certainly again
it could be a claim that you could have
more than one tenant bring and if you
know that could bring to either the
enforcement agency or the HRC or to HUD
it's also something that you could bring
to the attention of the the governor's
Council on disability because they do
they do also some accessibility and they
work with landlords but what you're
talking about potentially you know like
I said you could dock it on you know a
number of levels if there's
accessibility issues as a whole I would
definitely go to the governor's Council
on disa councils Council commission
Commission on disability thank you
um I would talk to them about that
accessibility as a whole but if there's
accessibility issues certainly they are
also you know again you know charges
that potentially could be brought other
at HUD or the HRC thank you I have an
unrelated question I'll wait for others
okay I'm gonna call and representative
McConkey
thank you Mr chairman um and um thank
you for being here two questions uh 55
and older community we have a town that
just finally passed its first Community
it looks lovely everything's fine but
there's a restriction in there that
unless you need a a caretaker that would
be a reason to have someone occupying a
home with someone under 55 but you had
mentioned that you could have up to 20
is that state statute up to 20 percent
so if you had a hundred units and it's a
community with a lot of women with
younger husbands then up to 20 of those
people could be living there yeah okay
according in accordance with the statute
it is actually specifically in the
statute as well okay thank you my second
was you had mentioned
um three units owner occupied does the
owner make the fourth unit or if there's
two units plus the plus I believe it's
three units total right is that what I I
believe it's three units total so the
homeowner would be one of so there could
be two under the federal statute it's
four units total so
um
uh but under the state statutes a little
more restrictive so it's three units
total thank you thank you Mr chairman uh
representative sorry thank you
um
as far as the exclusionary zoning you
you seem to
um kind of talk a little bit about not
really bringing many cases or
um or maybe HUD is bringing the cases
and you guys are not
um but it seems to me that
um
I guess I'm not unclear on on why
there's not more exclusionary zoning
cases and if
um do you do you need someone to come to
bring that to you or can you do some
research lights let's say we we see in
this committee a lot that people or or
towns are making kind of like the
existing structures
non-conforming anymore because they've
they've what was built let's say on a
quarter acre lot now they're requiring
five acre lots and so all of those
people are now being
negatively affected
by having more strict it's harder for
them to improve their property and also
another person
wanting the same thing as their neighbor
is no longer allowed to have that and
that seem like a ripe opportunity for
saying like you're excluding you know
people just like the person next door
from living in your community by you
know over zoning this and does that need
to be brought by someone within the town
or can the con your
kind of Department look on that on its
own and say hey this is this is um you
know problematic and we're going to
start kind of looking at that and and
you know putting a ceiling on that or do
you need something legislatively that
says hey if you have put more than you
know 90 if if more than five percent of
your you know homes in this area
um are now non-conforming based on your
change in regulation that that is
considered exclusionary zoning and then
that would Empower you to go do more I
guess
so I'm gonna sort of break that up just
a wee bit thank you for your question um
so the first the first answer to your
question is so HUD and the HRC we do
um
we do a lot of there's an overlap right
HUD enforces the federal fair housing
acts and we uh enforce the State Fair
Housing Act the short answer to your
question is we do keep an eye on what's
going on in our community we do have um
you know statutorily we can bring you
know charges our commissioners can bring
charges
um
uh so if there we saw something that was
exclusionary certainly we could
certainly people can bring them to those
types of cases to us and file docket
them as well
I think that you need to keep in mind
when it comes to exclusionary zoning
that is covered by our statute
we're talking about zoning that excludes
based on a protected class
so if that that zoning right caused
um you know uh sort of
let's
right low-income people aren't a
protected class though so that's kind of
a pro that's you know that that's not
protected but if let's say
um a zoning ordinance went through that
said
um you know
somebody but you know no one of this
insert race color national origin here
can't buy a house in this area right
that would exclude that protected class
so when it comes to some of these City
some cities and towns doing zoning based
on okay well we're gonna make it so if
you want to buy if you want to build on
a lot here now it has to be five acres
or if you want to build on a lot it has
to be one and a half acres or you can't
if it's not one and a half acres then
you can't expand your
um the buildings on your property right
um that type of zoning those changes to
zoning you know some would say is
exclusionary it's not protected it's not
um it has to be related to some
protected class so it isn't something
that we would be able to enforce if
there is something that shows that you
know there is a what we call a disparate
impact it means an impact on a bit a
larger scale on a specific protected
class then that would be something we
could look at like for for example if
the zoning takes place and you're seeing
that
um that there is a bigger impact on
let's just say
um uh you know a specific community
based on their national origin
um then that would be something we could
look at but if it's just you know there
it has an impact on lower income people
those folks aren't covered by our
statute according to what protected
classes we have listed
representative Damon
thank you thanks for taking my question
um so just following up on the
discussion with representative Alexander
about possibly denying a project because
of the impact on a school district
so I think what you were indicating was
someone would have to bring a case that
suggested that yeah the commission
doesn't
um
preemptively look at or set a policy on
something like that generally no we do
have the statutory authority to bring
our own charges so if we saw let's just
say the commissioner saw this popping up
in a number of communities right housing
developments are being reported To Us by
Representatives hey you might want to
look at you know this housing you know
I'm going to name towns I don't know if
they have these communities I'm just
naming random towns so you know uh
milford's denying a housing property
based on you know this alleged School
District issue uh Hillsboro is all of
these towns are if that was brought to
the commissioner's attention it might be
something that a commit we would BR the
Commissioners would bring a charge based
on
um and sort of
make it figure out what towns are this
is actually happening in and maybe bring
them all sort of all in so to speak
um but we don't we don't issue we're not
like the Attorney General's office where
we would issue an opinion if that I
guess that's sort of what you're asking
right yes okay yeah we don't we wouldn't
we wouldn't issue an opinion in that
manner we would we would take we would
have a commissioner bring a charge so
that we could investigate it and
sort of
so just to paraphrase I think it's
paraphrasing
there would have to be something
happening that is potentially
discrimination in order for you to rule
there wouldn't be a looking at
a development hasn't been proposed but a
community might have discussed that we
don't want this kind of development that
would have this impact yeah I mean if
that's out there if you have a board of
Select man or uh City Council
you know Alderman all the names that go
with the local government folks
certainly if they're talking about that
on the record and it's out there then
that would be something that you know
the commission would be interested in at
least taking you know potentially taking
a look at and just I mean we do work
with the Attorney General's office we
work with the Civil Rights unit really
fairly you know closely
um that so it would be something we
would probably be interested in because
a lot of times with things that happen
in New Hampshire communities it's like a
domino effect right once one Community
does it it sort of you know kind of
Falls other communities are also looking
at it so
um we could there's we are we've broke
double digits so we're actually at 10
staff members now so
anytime things like that are happening
in the community if you see that you
know something going on that you
question certainly bring it to our
attention sometimes we see you know we
do the best to you know scour you know
the union leader conquered monitor WMUR
but we don't always see what's going on
some of the smaller communities that may
or may not be doing things that are
questionable and as it relates to RSA
354a so if you see that or if it's
talked about on the public record it
would be something that the
Commissioners would be interested in
potentially pursuing representative
Gibbs thank you
um and uh thank you Sarah
you've pointed out correctly that if a
if a policy or local ordinance
um has a discriminatory effect it may
violate uh both the New Hampshire
anti-discrimination statute and the
federal fair housing act
um and you've pointed out also that this
um may be true uh with certain types of
zoning and I understand that um uh cases
dealing with such an issue
um are perhaps more likely to be brought
to HUD uh than to the New Hampshire
Human Rights Commission for various
reasons
um but there's another area where that
may also be true
um and that is with regard to source of
income now neither the New Hampshire
statute nor the federal fair housing
statute
um
provide that source of income by itself
constitutes illegal discrimination but
there are court cases including one in
Massachusetts
um that have found that source of income
discrimination
um May uh have a discriminatory effect
and thus violate the federal fair
housing act on the basis of race
discrimination
now has such a complaint ever been
brought to the New Hampshire commission
and if it has how did you deal with it
not that I'm aware of I've only been in
the commission for seven years so if one
has brought before that uh it it was
it's outside of my historical knowledge
um you know source of income has come up
I know in front of the legislature a
couple of years in a row back when I was
working for New Hampshire legal
assistance I know it had come up and you
know it is something that we look at we
don't look at we look at from the
perspective of if this were added how
would it work
it is source of income is protected
under Massachusetts state law
I know that when I was with New
Hampshire legal assistance we looked at
it from the perspective of landlords
denying folks who were on Section 8
vouchers as sort of an if you reported
you had a Section 8 voucher they said no
right away without even looking at
anything else so it's out there
statutorily it would have to change we
haven't had any case law before the
commission that would indicate that it
would be something I haven't seen any
case law as it relates to that disparate
impact on when it comes to race color
national origin I'm sure it's out there
but if I can find that case I will send
it to you but it was quite quite a while
ago theoretically also uh there could be
sex discrimination your statuses as well
um disability so that there are there
are a number of issues
um uh and um a source of income Bill
actually came before the legislature
this year but unfortunately it didn't
pass
um so thank you you're welcome
representative Reed thank you and I'm
gratified that uh representative yokella
and now representative Gibbs have both
touched on my original unrelated
question that I've waited a while which
is we've heard in this committee that
even the fact that we have zoning
ordinances at all stems back to the idea
that it went to a Supreme Court case as
I understand it that it was allowable on
the basis of the health safety and
Welfare of the people but that it's gone
very far afield of what that original
intent was and we can certainly point to
the historic trend for zoning ordinances
to be intended for racially and even a
nation of origin discriminatory
practices
probably we can prove that in New
Hampshire but certainly across the
country that has been historically the
case could we not bring forward a case
provided that we got the the people with
standing to bring forward this education
I'm absolutely positive we could
um to say that even though technically
it would be on you know the basis of
income level that not just
it's disproportionately affecting
certain races in nationalities of origin
but historically has proven to be done
for that very reason and I will just uh
speak to the fact that when I brought
forward a bill that would have reduced
uh property tax burden on low-income
people I was told by another
representative of my own party oh no no
we can't do that we'll bring up all the
wrong kinds of people from Massachusetts
right so um we know and there's plenty
of I'm sorry is there yes
can we not bring forward I feel like I'm
the only one you're doing that and
there's a lot of other long context I
will make sure to spread so
um can we not bring forward such a case
with that argument and saying this does
not
um match the original
um authorization for zoning ordinances
being for the health safety and Welfare
of people so the short answer is
um I mean I would say yes
um I sort of touched on it
um
I don't know how is it Yoko yokella okay
I was going to put a long e I'm sorry
um representative I I I touched on it
with his question there are disparate
impact cases desperate impact is sort of
that
um I hate to put it in the same bucket
but more of a class action right hey
this is really impacting a big group not
just a differing treatment case
differing treatment is where I'm
impacted right I'm being treated
differently based on my protected class
disparate impact is yes it can be
related to something out it could be
like I think Meryl brought up it could
be a case where
um yes the The Upfront issue is income
right but the backdrop of that and the
statistical information right shows that
this really is based on race color
national origin hey folks are getting
denied housing based on this or things
are or zoning is not changing or is
being changed to keep folks who are low
income out which has a disparate impact
means it impacts a protected protected
basis on a whole right it shows that
that's happening statistically so the
short answer to your question is yes it
could be a a charge could be wrought
like I said charges can be brought right
um anybody can you know anybody can
bring a charge right
um you know but then the commission's
job is to ensure that it is being
um it is enforcing RSA 354a in
accordance with the you know the statute
the case law and and I understood your
answers about disparate impact before
but my point was furthering it to say
and the intent the original intent of
many of these ordinances can be shown
historically to be for that intent to be
exclusionary not accidentally yeah right
and certainly that's something I mean
you know certainly that's something that
we would we potentially as we
investigate right could look at as well
what you know where where is this intent
where does this lie that's something
that would be part of the investigation
and that would certainly be something
that would be
um so the investigation is a bit like a
tennis match right
um we have a complainant right who
lodges their charge and then hits you
know serves the ball to the respondent
who answers right with something maybe a
health safety or you know whatever they
answer is their affirmative defense and
then it gets it gets hit back to the
complainant so that could be something
the complainant brings up you know after
an affirmative defense hey well let's
let's look at you know my statistical
information is backed up by the fact
that the original intent by this that's
a possibility I mean I'm just saying
that that that is a case that could
happen hypothetically
I have not seen a case like that come
through the commission okay you may
representative representative McConkey
thank you Mr chairman and to follow up
on Chairman's question
um
subdivisions higher density most times
many times will come down to children we
don't want children in school our
school-aged children a protective class
or do they have to be Navajo school-aged
children well that what's interesting is
that is the protected class would sort
of be familial status right families
with children
um I I think that would be where it
would fall under so the short answer is
no not necessarily in accordance with
the statute you could look at it you
know uh I think that you know this
alleged zoning issue would be something
that would be related to familial status
because essentially what you're saying
with not wanting school-aged children is
you're not wanting families with
children right so I think that's where
um that would fall under and it wouldn't
it would be sort of uh regardless of
their race color national origin et
cetera Etc so they so families could be
possibly a protective class thank you
yes okay representative hello
thank you uh I'm not sure if this is a
loud question or not but if not then you
can uh follow up separately with me
um
if there is a municipality
hypothetically that
um
that
um had
um like a business come and say we would
like to create a tattoo parlor in your
state yeah or in your municipality do
you have any regulations on that and the
municipality
quickly drafted a regulation saying to
be a tattoo artist you had to be a
licensed physician in New Hampshire
would that
stray somehow into any of your buckets
that is like you're trying to
discriminate
tattoo parlors because it doesn't make
any sense that they would need to be
licensed positioned in the state of New
Hampshire it
I don't see it falling within our bucket
okay however I mean it is there are
other staff statutory land there is
other statutory language about
um you know licensing and et cetera et
cetera that that potentially could fall
under I suppose
representative Gibbs uh just to clarify
quickly uh families with children are a
protected class in New Hampshire yes I'm
sorry did I not make that clear families
with children are a protected class
you know the minute it came out of my
mouth representative Gibbs I was like I
didn't know if that does that no yes um
so in that sense children are protected
doesn't matter what race or national or
general right or
whatever
um and then
um uh just just one more uh follow-up
question
um uh
in order for
um a complaint to be investigated by the
commission
um it can't just be discrimination
against someone it has to be
discrimination against someone that has
either the intent or effect
um of discrimination on the basis of one
of the areas covered by the statute that
is a discriminatory effect not on say
tattoo parlors but on businesses
um uh that are very heavily patronized
by people of a particular national
origin or that serves almost entirely
people with disabilities that could be a
discriminatory effect under uh New
Hampshire and federal law right so
differing treatment has to have that
intent right if I'm treating you
differently based on your insert
protected class here right there is an
intent part of that I am intending to
treat you differently disparate impacts
a little bit different right because
disparate impact is looking at a potent
what what is supposed to be a neutral
policy a neutral law uh zoning ordinance
Etc that is supposed to be neutral right
and it's not so there's no there's no
intent with disparate impact with those
cases where
um we're looking at policies
um there is if we're talking about
individual basis
does that is that confusing follow-up
and uh sorry
um uh are we holding you up from your
doctor's appointment I do have to leave
in about oh probably a minute and a half
I was hoping okay uh I'll be as as fast
as I can
um
ah sorry
if
sorry I've just I've just lost my train
um I'll have to ask you this question uh
directly later on my apologies it's okay
and I'm happy to if if you have
questions
um please you know either email Ani um
or or myself or the commission and we
certainly will answer the question sorry
I just got it back I'll be as quick as I
can
um isn't it possible sometimes rarely to
show intent by the series of events
um and I'm speaking of the case that I
had long ago uh at HUD where
um uh there was a change in the statute
that would have required
um a town to make a change in who it
allowed and it would have brought in
um a larger number of racial minorities
from surrounding cities
um based on the changes in uh the laws
covering HUD assisted housing and the
town as soon as this happened it passed
a new ordinance essentially blocked
talking that type of housing
wouldn't that conceivably show
discriminatory intention yeah I I mean I
think that that would definitely be that
fact pattern would be a case that would
be Doc could be docketed with us right
um because it does show to that pattern
I think that goes with representative
reads what what she was also saying
um you know if it if that with that
intent of the statute right you look at
that fact pattern all the way through
not just from especially if you're
looking at a neutral policy you look at
it from when the pilot why was the
policy put in place you know where are
we going with this policy what is the
impact of this policy so that would
definitely be something that was
chargeable and sounds like it was with
HUD so thank you great well thank you
very much you're welcome and like I said
appreciate it please feel free to you
know email us any other questions you
have or any other assistance we can be
um that's part of what we do and that's
part of what we want to do we want to do
more education than enforcement
um frankly so
um but please feel free to email us
questions thank you very much thank you
I'm sorry I have to run if you'd like to
say yeah thank you you're okay
all right I think we're gonna take a two
minute break and then we're gonna hear
from
um Greg from Department of Housing or
Urban Development thanks
okay welcome back I wanna I wanna
welcome Greg Carson
um to the special committee on housing
I'm sure you're used to being in this
building frequently
um but I
I appreciate you coming in to talk about
um this is from the federal
um Department of Housing and Urban
Development and you are the director of
the New Hampshire Branch correct yes
great thank you for coming
there we go okay
didn't have all this high-tech stuff
when I was sitting in that chair when it
was over there I guess it's been a while
um I think it's been let's see
1999 was the last time I chaired a
Commerce Committee hearing
only because uh
I was back for my from being down in DC
for a couple weeks so
um so I'm Greg Carson I'm the director
of the U.S Department of Housing and
Urban Development for uh the uh
Manchester Field office we go back and
forth between calling them the state or
the city so sometimes it's one state or
one one city so uh but we've stayed
consistent we are the Manchester Field
office opposed to the New Hampshire
field office for whatever reason
and
um Meryl who I used to work with
um had asked if I could come up and just
talk for a couple of minutes
um about some of the things that HUD is
doing in terms of housing I'm more
expecting you to ask questions than me
to just kind of give you I mean I could
give you a two-hour lecture on all the
things that HUD does here in New
Hampshire and you'd be surprised that
you know it's almost
it's almost a billion dollars a year
um in actual activity here in New
Hampshire when you take a look at all of
the FHA insurance for individual family
homes all the commercial FHA Loans Etc
so
but um
HUD has a few programs that directly get
or the state gets direct funding for
housing and housing activities
and the one thing to keep in mind is
that a lot of the the funding that comes
in
is housing in the broadest terms if we
set aside all of the Section 8 and all
the individual
um uh housing authorities in New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority the
Manchester Nashua Portsmouth there's 21
of them here in the state if you set
aside the funding that goes to them
directly
the remainder of the funding actually
comes through various state agencies
like cdfa or um Finance Etc
and so we we put in about 50 million
dollars a year into New Hampshire the
last few years it was about half of that
prior to covid it will go back down much
to the Chagrin of
the governor it'll go back down
somewhere between 50 and say 24 million
dollars because that's about how much
we're normally putting into the into the
state programs there's some of that
money actually
gets divided by formula so in many cases
and I'm going to say we a lot is it
because it's just hard for me to say you
know the government or that we the
states the people because I'm a taxpayer
too
um we get about 24 million dollars in
funding some of that is as I said
formula grant money which means
we get the minimum amount
based on our
in the calculations for Grants are often
done by a formula that was created 35
years ago and it includes and it's a big
secret how they do it every year and how
they twist it around But it includes you
know the age of the popular the age of
the housing stock in the state
um some of its you know population based
um some of it's based on economic values
and that but it we end up a lot a lot of
times getting like the minimum amount so
I'll give you an example
um almost two weeks ago the government
the federal government did another
allocation for
um the Housing Trust Fund programs in
New Hampshire we've had a Housing Trust
Fund program right now for
five or six years I think that's about
it
no more than six years I think um it
started off with some funding from the
federal government
that was going to International Finance
Authority and then the state
added created a state Housing Trust Fund
and there's finally that comes from the
legislature that does that
the allocations for New Hampshire has
always been about three to five million
dollars a year for the Housing Trust
Fund
um
we've already done that allocation this
year and we just uh the secretary
announced it to be another five million
dollars coming into actually three
million dollars coming to the state
based on the formula grant process we
probably would have ended up getting
about 1.1 to 1.2 million dollars if we
based it actually you know on uh the
other factors that are normally used in
the grant so we met the minimum floor uh
Montana of you know some of the smaller
States Vermont that we all get the
minimum
um and so when that money comes in like
that whether it's the annual funding or
funding that comes in sporadically
presidential disasters things like that
that funding is pretty Loosely tied to
housing and that we give as much
discretion as we possibly can to the
state so that they can use the money in
the way they feel it's best being used
one of the biggest surprises
um I got when I came to HUD I had
previously run um
uh most of the U.S mints IRS Electronic
Tax Administration and
Medicare during the Bush Administration
I was very surprised how I came to HUD
was that HUD actually doesn't do any
direct funding to individuals
um they fund through other people they
fund through banks they fund through you
know state agencies and non-profits and
there's a thing called the continuums of
care which are there's three here at New
Hampshire one in Manchester one in
Nashua and one they call the balance of
state if
we use balance the state a lot because
if at city or town does not have Housing
Authority they go to hedge Housing
Finance Authority as they're provided
for balance of state so these um
continues of care actually make the
decision it's the continuums are made up
of local agencies the city
um uh there's you know HUD provides
technical assistance to the group and
then you know usually there's so
depending on which program is one of the
HUD employees will participate but the
idea is to let the cities and towns or
the state actually make the decisions on
how to spend the money so even though
something might be called a Community
Development block grant
could be used to secure a piece of
property or clear a piece of property so
that housing could be built
or you know you know Manchester's I'll
use Manchester as an example
um when you get off of 293 on Queen City
Bridge excuse me on um
I can't remember Queen City Bridge
the bridge was redone with all HUD
funding from the Community Development
block grants I mean that's very flexible
I mean that money could actually even be
used to invest in a business
um
through cdfa or somebody else and can be
used to just to make sure to increase
the number of jobs that are available so
the funding is can be used really
flexibly so um
like you said this you know
um it has been about 24 million dollars
a year it's last couple years have been
50 million or so and those are big kind
of round numbers and it's divided among
multiple programs but um you know for
the better part I mean I think that's
the easiest way to kind of describe it
it's supposed to go through all the
individual
um programs themselves
um so we also spend about 120 million
dollars a year
um
let's just see if there's excusing them
about 180 million dollars a year total
on housing that normally people would
consider Section 8 which you know kind
of has a negative connotation to it
which it shouldn't because Section 8
just happens to be the number in the uh
the law that actually allows us to
provide um housing funding but Section 8
can be individuals receiving a voucher
which literally is a certificate they
can take and go into the marketplace and
rent an apartment it could be a
um a for-profit or a non-profit Builder
or a housing manager that owns a
building and we've designated units
within those buildings as Section 8
fundable
or it um it could be just the
traditional what people think of the
Section 8 housing where we funded
um like uh Manchester housing authority
has a number of buildings and number of
Apartments dot dot so it can be the
government building it could be the
local agency you know Manchester it
could be a non-profit families in
transition Harbor care Etc or it could
be a an actual Builder Steve Lewis
Builder uh was a one that we did a lot
of low-income brand new housing being
built down in Southern Southern New
Hampshire so
so that kind of sums up what we do at
least from the housing side
um and uh I'm not sure what your
interests are I've obviously followed
the housing issues pretty closely
um
taught Taylor Castle everything he knows
so all the stuff that happens over there
in terms of housing
um Taylor used to be the regional
administrator for uh here in New England
and that
um and so I and
um some of you may know I have a
relationship with somebody in the that
other side of the building or
on the other side of the hall there
where there's only 24 people so um
obviously I get a lot of questions from
people
rep centers all the time and I try and
be as helpful as I can
um there's really not much that we do
that's not
um you know available publicly for
information
tremendous amount of information both on
the HUD website but also on the national
traveling Finance Authority website so
thank you are there are there questions
for Greg yes represent McConkey thank
you Mr chairman uh Community block
grants if you are I believe that's a
part of the discussion and if you're not
part of the 20 21 housing authorities
does it my area up uh Carroll County is
that administered who would
who deter who do you make application to
does that go through the regional
Planning Commission or to your
department so um I'll just a little bit
further explanation the Community
Development block grants are given to
the state and entitlement communities
again and you'll you'll recognize why it
seems kind of goofy at this point
um you know Manchester and Nashua
obviously are entitlement communities
because of the large their size but um
Dover Portsmouth Rochester
um are also entitlement communities
because you think about in the 60s the
Air Force Base was out towards the
Seacoast much bigger population the
housing stock was very old so they get
their own direct funding every other
community in the state goes through cdfa
for funding and
we don't have entitlement counties here
in New Hampshire so it is the cities
actually applied directly to the state
or cities or child Supply that directly
through the state and in a lot of times
it's money that they used to start a
program where they're using multiple
different programs of government to get
stuff done which town do you live in
um
so um there's a couple of programs that
um we actually did a Main Street program
14 years ago in Ossipee yeah
Community about block grant money thank
you representative Gibbs thank you Mr
chairman
um and thank you uh Mr Carson for coming
uh
just uh to clarify
um uh the entitlement communities
um essentially receive their funding uh
based on their population
um and to some extent on their poverty
level population
um and then uh non-entitlement
communities uh can apply to the state
um for a grant
um and that usually a one-time grant for
a year or two years
um
uh and the uh community that isn't an
entitlement Community would apply to the
state with a proposal uh and that would
be uh the cdfa that you were referring
to that's the
um uh State Community Development
Department essentially uh is that all
correct yes yeah yes thank you
represent your color
thank you
um my I and I hope the interest of the
committee is mostly about
um barriers to housing in general that
that
um whether that be
um development of housing
um maybe even something that you might
see about you know development of
Section 8 housing or or just general
housing barriers in in general anything
that you have that you see that
from your experience had is somewhere
that we should look as far as trying to
help alleviate or fix or or
um incentivize
um
what we describe as the housing crisis
in New Hampshire sure
um I meant to literally bring my HUD hat
with me
so that I could take it off and put it
on the table say okay you know what
we're going to talk about is not an
official representation of the computer
I am not allowed to actually you know
Advocate policy or testify or provide
you know if you're testimony on any of
the four behalf of any kind of
legislation I will just kind of take my
hot my HUD hat off I mean I'm not going
out of bounds or anything but
um zoning board chairman in Londonderry
for a decade I've been doing this for
years I was on the committee one we did
manufactured housing reinforced
manufactured housing with the uh um the
first right of refusal so I know a lot
about housing so I'm going to add a
whole bunch of things here that you know
just don't generally revolve it just
particularly in housing the official
thing from position from HUD is that you
know the idea is to lower one of our
goals is to lower the barriers to
development of housing that's just a
general you know broad goal here in New
Hampshire the limits
um and I'm going to use
my own example uh the limits are really
so dictated by the communities less so
than the state um the state you know
it's got you know broad General
guidelines as to you know building codes
things like that but it's usually it's
the committee it's the communities
themselves that actually have the
largest influence as I said I was the
chairman of the zoning board Monday for
a decade and
um a
when I first moved here in the
um late 80s well 89 90 time frame
um the housing market had just had a
another kind of downturn
um and so uh being an active person in
the community on the budget committee
that we came up with the idea to
actually go out and buy all of the
development rights for all the apple
orchards in Londonderry so that nobody
could come in and build developments
um because we're trying to limit you
know the amount of money that this the
community would spend
um we did that at the time because we
thought that was a kind of the smart
thing to do
um we find you know
20 years later or we'll go back and like
oh wait a minute we brought up all these
development rights and we've basically
just driven up the cost of housing in
the local community and we've driven
most of the development to be senior
housing
so we ended up having from a dollar and
cents perspective we end up building
more expensive housing in terms of the
Town than we did had we and um not
bottles development rights so it's
zoning it's the cities and towns you
know uh restrictive zoning
um I actually think New Hampshire does a
great job at zoning in general but um
you know uh it's an easy thing to point
a finger at when people are talking
about the development of housing
um uh if if you saw the housing Atlas
that came out last week
I think there's some flaws in that
um and it's you really have to
understand you know the um the zoning in
each individual town and just kind of a
little more you know more than just a
cursory level of zoning in general to
understand you know where all I think
the percentages they're using when
they're narrowing It Down based on what
items they put in there are a bit well
actually I think some of them far off
but
um the thing is there's develop a land
and there are communities that you know
tend to have
um
larger lot size Etc but many communities
have adopted or are you know looking at
things like planned um I think it's
planned Urban Development let me give
you example again Londonderry
um we have on our
um uh zoning um our building plan to do
to develop communities where the lot
size are as small as a quarter of an
acre for single-family homes we have a
separate area a separate zoning area for
manufactured housing in the more older
traditional sense of manufactured
housing where people think of mobile
homes versus manufactured housing that a
lot of mobile home or manufactured
housing parks are being replaced with
where they just bring over bring a one
story Ranch and two pieces and they plop
it on the lot and on the on the
foundation so it looks like more
traditional housing and you talk with
the Community Development Finance
Authority earlier so we did so
those are you know it's it's more it's
really the community levels that have
you know anything that kind of restricts
housing but there's still plenty of
buildable land and lots here okay so if
you could put your
HUD hat back on I have a question
regarding
um
HUD inspections Section 8 inspections I
think we we talked about how you have a
series of inspections that happen you
have obviously if there's Section 8 or
getting Federal money there's a federal
inspection and then there's a local code
inspection and then there's probably
something like can we talk about
inspections is there a way to streamline
it because I know the fact do the feds
allow a municipality to be a certified
HUD inspector where you know somebody in
the municipality can inspect for you
guys so it's maybe one inspection
instead of 12.
um
so
every year to three years
um
uh buildings that are you know
owners who have housing that are
receiving funding for Section Eight
um have an inspection a react inspection
and it varies and there's a risk
management formula that decides based on
previous you know scores the area the
development um you know the community
Etc on how soon that happens in there
um HUD actually doesn't do those
inspections we actually pay private
inspectors to do that work and there is
um New Hampshire Housing Finance
Authority and
um Keen Housing Authority particularly
by the lead of you know with Keen in the
lead they have looked at trying to get a
certified kind of inspection so they
could combine those things
um HUD would be fine I mean under HUD
regulations
if the Hut of the inspection that HUD is
doing or is required the react
inspection is being done it would not be
a problem for the state or the town to
accept that same inspection the
standards would have to uh wouldn't be
amendable
um would you say this would you say the
standards for the HUD inspection are
more stringent or less stringent than a
municipal
all right
um
that would be a hard one to just save
some of my head because I mean there's a
lot of functionalities right right but
it's not just that but the the S the
inspection standards everybody's
expecting inspecting the same thing as
to what degree I I have actually seen
where
one inspector tried to fail a building
because
um five Apartments had little pinholes
in the screens and the windows to allow
mosquitoes and at the same time I've
seen some housing that had mold and
other stuff that would seem to be
getting through inspections that
shouldn't have been getting through so
uh the the inspection standards like
appraisal standards whether it's for
Federal Loan or state loan or you know a
Community Bank all are pretty much the
same kind of Standards there's very
little change in between those
so if I'm sorry to believe this if
there's
if they're all the same standard why do
we have multiple inspections because the
law requires multiple inspections
because we have
State inspectors and federal inspect the
federal government as the funder is
always going to have inspections up you
know that are required by our standards
think of it this way um you know the
building codes there's a National
Building Code there's a State Building
Code and then there's a community
building code they really need all three
well normally it's all the enforcement
that's done locally it's the same thing
here with you know a federal inspection
you know that's Federal inspection for
react depending on you know how often
they get it you've got the same issue
you've got the building inspector in
this particular Community who's also
given the same exact task to do the
inspections so it's
you're required at the state level
required at the federal level and you
know the communities then inspect based
on their particular building code in
town okay and that's why you have three
now does it have to be three I think
innovatively
you should have I mean you have the
oversight of two of those three so well
if if you you know would make a law or
enable municipalities to adopt the HUD
regulations and then
the inspector would inspect those
regulations and that would be
satisfactory
for Saint local is that something the
legislature has to enable or and
actually um the legislature and this
committee actually
um drafted and put forward to the house
um to do exactly that on manufactured
housing installations
installation standards
um the committee had just adopted the
Federal Regulation actually the law was
written kind of creatively so it just
adopts the current federal law on
installation standards great thank you
representative uh yes thank you Mr
Claire I just wanted to clarify
um
um what type of inspections you're
asking about are you asking about the
Section 8 voucher inspections in
particular
I mean those inspections seem are
from what I know there's like 70 pages
of things that a landlord would have to
follow so right that seems like pretty
strict but I think is there a different
inspection that we're talking yes I
think that our guest is referring to
Section 8 um Building Inspections for
Project based section eight there's a
big difference between you know the um
about your inspections and then the
project-based inspections which go from
floor to ceiling you know um just every
every type of um
regulation you can think of on housing
for your section 8
voucher inspections are usually the unit
and then limited common areas so there's
a huge difference I think so um
thank you
so I you know again I'm trying to make
as broad as what we're trying to do so
um yeah so there is there if the
building like Manchester housing
authority building or if a building is
completely funded by Hud okay that is a
much larger you know deeper a number of
pages of detail to go through however
every place everybody that has a voucher
when they go to that building
um so we don't actually I said we don't
actually do the inspections same way
that we don't actually issue the
vouchers
um we pay New Hampshire Housing Finance
Authority or the Manchester housing
authority or that to do those and so
part of the process of somebody being
able to use their voucher in an
individual apartment in the marketplace
is that the
the unit has to pass the same health and
wellness safety standards that you know
any other unit would in terms of
habitability and that is um we actually
have Manchester housing authority does
that for the most part New Hampshire
Housing Finance Authority does that for
the most part but um all of the other uh
individual housing authorities do that
also but there is a different set of
inspections but it's all the same kind
of things it's you know if the window if
the you know if there's leaking there's
mold there's not it's all the same
general family of things it's just the
checklist is much longer because we
don't have the We the People the federal
government don't have an interest in the
actual Realty when it's at somebody's
individual apartment or that where we do
have that in terms of uh you know like a
you know if if we've funded them a
building
um for non-profit or for a for-profit
developer because we need to make sure
that our investment all of our
investments protected too so okay that's
really the difference thank you uh
representative
thank you I wanted to go back
all the way to where you said the um
town was buying development rights
um
a couple of questions about that
are they when you say the town is buying
development rights is that kind of like
buying like conservation rights or is
that a different section of law or and
is are those in perpetuity or are they
able to sell them off and have they sell
them off
those
yeah great question because when we did
it originally we thought it was in
perpetuity
um so at the time and I don't know the
current state you know the current
status of the law a town could go and
buy negotiate for the development rights
for a piece of property and it would be
like a conservation trust where the
landowner still can you know have their
Farm their apple orchards golf course
whatever the whatever they were using
that would qualify that property say is
you know agricultural
Etc but may also be called you know
maybe like Illinois has a big huge air
one zone all the Appalachians were in
that ar-1 zone let me just when they
developed the uh um the zoning in town
so they were the town was purchasing the
rights to develop that land if and when
the the land owner sold the land or
decided they wanted to um excuse me on
any transfer of the land any future
development developer or anybody coming
in to buy it would be restricted on
those same
um the same uh purchased rights that the
town did so
you know no single-family housing no
multi-family housing no and there was a
laundry list of items that they couldn't
do
um max apple orchards was a big huge
Appalachian Londonderry
um uh the town had bought development
rights from
um the owner there and
35 years later the
um the owner decided they went to buy
those rights back and there was an
option to do so and pieces of land
mostly so that other developments could
be done including development that the
town wanted could be you know purchased
back by a developer coming in or the the
original
um beneficiary of the payment from the
town they could buy those rights back
and I think the
the position of the taxpayers in town
it's softened a bit about making them
you know in perpetuity because it was so
restrictive that there's a lot of
development that couldn't be done
um in fact the um development that's
going on at Exit four
um in 4A
um uh you know without being able to
purchase some of those rights back they
probably wouldn't have happened
so
uh representative Reed
thank you
um so let's say a property when it gets
developed is using federal funds to be
developed for affordable housing and
after those initial inspections when
it's built
um many years later
and I in my experience it was like a
limit of like fifth the the the federal
funds came with a string of like 15
years or 20 years or something like that
depending on the program
um but at that point they're no longer
maintaining to that level in other words
they would not pass that inspection
today what
what uh recourse do residents have so
typically what happens those kinds of
property so
just take one quick side step here so
depending on the source of the funds and
what the funds were intended for there
could be as little as five years of
restriction on what was done with the
say like a building that was rehab for a
community center something versus 15
years for a different program all the
way up to 40 years
um
uh
and there are actually a lot of
properties out there with 40-year
restrictions on you know the uh on the
buildings
um
the typically what happens is a lot of
communities that have their own housing
authorities
they'll come back and refinance those
buildings with a new set of loans to
rehab them to bring them up to standards
I mean we give you know HUD actually
designs incentives or congress designs
incentives that HUD implements uh for it
to do so so heating systems air
conditioning systems there was a grant
for doing the light bulbs and things
like that so a lot of those buildings do
get brought up to standard because they
they can't pass inspection anymore so
they tend to stay and it's like I said a
lot of housing that was built originally
for
um it could be section 202 or section
811 which is senior disabled housing
um
or you know could be you know um any of
the various versions of the Section 8
funding and you want to get into like
multi-family versus public housing
funding Etc but generally the buildings
that are publicly owned or those that
are owned by non-profits and management
nonprofits they go out to the
marketplace in some cases um or they you
know come back to HUD if they go if all
of the restrictions have expired they
can go to the marketplace and do that if
there's still a lot of restrictions on
them they come to us because we have to
waive our first position on any um uh
claims
and we actually did a program a number
of years ago and there is the Keen
housing authorities in a very unique
position where they actually sold all of
their
housing
to a non-profit which same director same
board of directors Etc
they're all now uh private they're owned
by a non-profit which the Keen Housing
Authority manages all of the units for
them they place people in them and they
were able to take advantage of any cost
savings by running the program that way
they were able to then take that and
reinvest it in the buildings they were
able to get private loans and they were
able to develop more additional units
without HUD funding whatsoever all from
the non-profit that was formed it's
called the moving to work program we
tried to do that
um again but it was the programs became
a lot of restrictions so HUD did another
program
um that basically did that's a very
similar thing where
um you know the Housing Authority could
sell off their property to a non-profit
that was you know I mean all kinds of
strings attached obviously back to the
city but they were able to uh go out and
uh refund and refinance and rebuild
um in a number of places in the state
any more questions
well thank you very much for coming and
answering our questions and sure giving
us a little bit more information
appreciate it and feel free to contact
me if you think of something else you
want to ask or send me an email it's
kind of a broad generalized topic I mean
it's so big that it's I can't cover it
very much so it's a lot of information I
mean we've been doing we've been days at
this so
um is there anything that anyone would
like to bring up before we adjourn for
the day
go ahead represent Gibbs thank you um
yes I I do just have a question
um are we going to have a presentation
from a state engineer on
um things like septic Leach fields and
modern septic technology
yes my plan is to bring in Des at some
point but an engineer not like the top
level Des but somebody that does the
ground the engineering I think what we
need as an engineer that's what I was
asking about thank you perfect
um I also have
um distributed uh section
some rsas to you one was one is
regarding
um local state and local building codes
and collection of impact fees as well as
state um
uh building code so my intention is to
look at this
um regarding uh what was brought up this
morning with buildings that were built
previous you know older buildings that
may not run up to code maybe we could
find somewhere where we could say any
building that's built before 1950 could
follow a different set of codes than the
current one because if people are
building to code at a certain new
buildings to code the older ones are a
lot smaller maybe more impactful maybe
they have different staircases things
like that so it might help
redeveloping or rehabilitating older
buildings if we can LAX up that code so
I don't know anybody's thoughts on that
but it's definitely something I want to
look at so I encourage you to take a
look at it question or clarification so
when we talk about um newer building
codes on older billing codes could we
talk about the lead paint
um law which I think is a great example
um right now any building built after
1970 I think it's 1976 is uh does not
have lead and that's sort of like a a
break off any building before possibly
has fled is that one way to look at that
that is certainly something I'm willing
to entertain
um the lead maybe that's the date you
know maybe that is the one we pick but
I'm just throwing out an arbitrary date
for that but
not building codes but you mentioned
impact fees are in the same handout uh
based on our earlier presentation and
the negative or cooling effect of impact
fees and other similar fees I'm
wondering if it wouldn't be an
interesting idea to have a like
prohibition on impact fees for
developers who were specifically
developing affordable housing
or maybe just a discount something like
that
um and there's I'm trying to look at the
one Nate's just sent it to me
so it in in what you can charge an
impact fee for right so
um there's some that make sense and
there's some that don't but I will leave
it up to the committee to figure that
out but I'd like to look into that as
well
great all right well thank you everyone
we're returning for the oh representing
we don't have a meeting scheduled yet so
stand by
okay
we will probably pick
um Tuesdays or third Tuesdays or
Thursdays now that committees don't need
free as frequently
um we should have access to these rooms
perfect thank you